SPEAKER_01: Hello and welcome to Sparks of the Past.
SPEAKER_01: We're now in session six.
SPEAKER_01: The last session dealt with the group at the undersea base, Elyon, and
SPEAKER_01: trying to figure out what happened to this particular clone guy of Mercer.
SPEAKER_01: They decided to be a little bit more gentle and talk to him.
SPEAKER_01: He explains that certain high political figures and military leaders are part of a
SPEAKER_01: clone rebirth program, that if they're willing to give up a lot of their
SPEAKER_01: generational wealth, they can, when they are destroyed, be reborn in a clone body.
SPEAKER_01: If the death is not public, they can return to whatever they're doing, but if the
SPEAKER_01: death is public, they have to leave the system.
SPEAKER_01: There obviously was something of people trying to stop him from going.
SPEAKER_01: The group decides to get his support in
SPEAKER_01: helping him get off system and not be possibly taken out by any other assassins.
SPEAKER_01: And in exchange, he gives the passcode for his data pad that the players have and
SPEAKER_01: access to his home
SPEAKER_01: on Jardin.
SPEAKER_01: The group then decides to raise the sunken ship boat.
SPEAKER_01: They are able to get there on the TSS Perfunder, and while Saatchi
SPEAKER_01: scouts ahead and is able to kind of explore some things, players are able to, with
SPEAKER_01: submarine and
SPEAKER_01: scuba suits, able to get inside, and by hook and by crook able to get the
SPEAKER_01: ship
SPEAKER_01: Pressurized and lifted to the surface.
SPEAKER_01: We ended last game with them having gotten
SPEAKER_01: the ship to the surface and having understood what is the basic part of the cargo
SPEAKER_01: and by selling the cargo they could probably get the ship at least into space
SPEAKER_01: without killing them.
SPEAKER_01: One of the things I have added in the Foundry if you are all interested is
SPEAKER_01: There's one called the Volante Shipboat.
SPEAKER_01: I'm going to activate this and this is actually a playable map of the smuggler
SPEAKER_01: shipboat.
SPEAKER_01: So people want to know where they're going and what they're doing.
SPEAKER_01: We have that.
SPEAKER_01: The beds that you see on the lower deck are all bunk beds.
SPEAKER_01: So there is a total of four singles and there
SPEAKER_01: are two doubles. And that should be enough for the players involved.
SPEAKER_01: Pilot is the only person that has an actual seat because they need an actual
SPEAKER_01: gravity assisting seat. Everyone else just stands if they're helping out with
SPEAKER_01: sensors and stuff.
SPEAKER_01: And people who are dealing with power are going to be where the power or the
SPEAKER_01: other piece is.
SPEAKER_01: So inside the
SPEAKER_01: actual cabin
SPEAKER_01: is pretty much going to be pilot and sensors, and everything else is going to be
SPEAKER_01: engineer people away dealing with the actual engines.
SPEAKER_03: So it's like a Jim Hadar ship where there are no siege.
SPEAKER_03: Except
SPEAKER_03: for the one. You broke up.
SPEAKER_03: You broke up and I could not hear you.
SPEAKER_03: Would you please repeat your statement, Steinbach?
SPEAKER_03: Yes. He said, is it like a... Sorry,
SPEAKER_03: I
SPEAKER_00: got it.
SPEAKER_00: So it's like a Jim Hadar...
SPEAKER_00: A warship from Star Trek Deep Space Nine where there were no chairs on the bridge
SPEAKER_00: except for the pilot chair.
SPEAKER_00: Yes.
SPEAKER_01: I did not know that reference off the top when I only heard a scattering of
SPEAKER_01: that.
SPEAKER_01: But yes, there's only the pilot chair.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Now, what do you guys want to do?
SPEAKER_01: You do have...
SPEAKER_01: Mercer is
SPEAKER_01: still on the
SPEAKER_01: medical facility kind of main area.
SPEAKER_01: The Profoundur is still underwater.
SPEAKER_01: But all of you guys are just bouncing on the top of the surface.
SPEAKER_01: Now that it's also been, by the way, pressurized,
SPEAKER_01: It is incredibly smelly.
SPEAKER_01: There is
SPEAKER_01: active algae and guck just everywhere.
SPEAKER_01: Now that it actually is breathable air, if you guys want to not be in your
SPEAKER_01: vac suits, it's pretty disgusting.
SPEAKER_03: I think I'll stay in my vac suit for now.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: It has been a little more than a hundred years of it being underwater.
SPEAKER_01: So it's going to take more than a pressure hose to get rid of the smell.
SPEAKER_01: You have coral in the venting and things like that.
SPEAKER_03: A
SPEAKER_03: free ship is
SPEAKER_01: a free ship.
SPEAKER_00: Can I start running... I think I have sensors.
SPEAKER_00: Can I start running diagnostics on the ship to see how bad it is so that
SPEAKER_00: we know if we
SPEAKER_00: move to repair this?
SPEAKER_00: I want to try to start putting together a list of what repairs and what parts
SPEAKER_00: we're going to do.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Here's the bit.
SPEAKER_01: With sensors, I will let you see
SPEAKER_01: some of the electrical things, but it's going to take someone with like a
SPEAKER_01: I'm a shadering more kind of vibe to figure out some of the other ones.
SPEAKER_02: Okay.
SPEAKER_02: That makes sense to me. You said a machinery sort of vibe, you said?
SPEAKER_02: Is that what you said? Yeah, like mechanics.
SPEAKER_02: Mechanics?
SPEAKER_02: Okay. Yeah.
SPEAKER_02: In the same time, I would go around with the mechanic stuff if anyone wants to
SPEAKER_02: do it with me.
SPEAKER_01: Steinbach got an amazing roll. If you want to roll your mechanics, and if that
SPEAKER_01: roll's amazing, I can just give the list.
SPEAKER_02: He's like, there's a lot of stuff.
SPEAKER_02: I don't see why. Yeah, sure.
SPEAKER_03: Mechanics,
SPEAKER_03: Normal, Public.
SPEAKER_03: Not great.
SPEAKER_03: It's good enough.
SPEAKER_03: I'm happy to give the list.
SPEAKER_03: Okay, let me pull it up.
SPEAKER_03: Actors.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: I'm going to read this and then I'm going to paste it, okay?
SPEAKER_01: Awesome.
SPEAKER_01: Damage thrusters. So all pilot checks when you're out of the water is going to be
SPEAKER_01: automatically minus one on the roll.
SPEAKER_01: Oof.
SPEAKER_01: The moment you push above 3Gs, even in space, there's a noticeable
SPEAKER_01: vibration across the entire ship.
SPEAKER_01: That's cool.
SPEAKER_01: Temperamental systems.
SPEAKER_01: There are generations of undocumented repairs behind the access panels.
SPEAKER_01: Electronics or mechanicals made to diagnose problems are automatically minus one on
SPEAKER_01: the successes, but does not affect the difficulty to repair it once you have
SPEAKER_01: successfully identified it.
SPEAKER_01: Then you have difficulty repair, minus one in all repair terms.
SPEAKER_01: Half the components have been replaced with parts from later models, civilian
SPEAKER_01: equipment, or other things that was never intended to fit.
SPEAKER_01: The next one is asymmetric drive response.
SPEAKER_01: One of the maneuver drive elements produces slightly more thrust than the other one.
SPEAKER_01: During emergency acceleration or violent evasive maneuvers, the pilot must make
SPEAKER_01: another pilot check at minus one or the ship will tilt slightly.
SPEAKER_01: This is not a problem during normal non-conobat or non-rolled flight.
SPEAKER_00: Sorry about that. I had a flight issue. Do I need to make a pilot roll?
SPEAKER_01: No.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_02: Well, it's a good thing we have an awesome pilot, because this is sounding bad.
SPEAKER_01: We're talking about all the things that are wrong with your guys' free ship.
SPEAKER_03: The good news is...
SPEAKER_03: The answer is everything, including the smell.
SPEAKER_01: So...
SPEAKER_01: Five is it does have a reputation amongst older spacers, smugglers, fencers, and
SPEAKER_01: customs officers.
SPEAKER_01: They may notice the hull configuration.
SPEAKER_01: All underworld contacts, you'll have a plus one on social checks.
SPEAKER_01: But in recognition by law enforcement can be a conversation of, oh, well, yeah, it
SPEAKER_01: was this other ship, but we bought it when those guys died or whatever.
SPEAKER_01: You may have to actually answer for those types of statements.
SPEAKER_01: How very Firefly.
SPEAKER_01: Six is damage centers. There's a minus one to all electronic sensor checks.
SPEAKER_01: The short range array works reasonably well, as well as does all internal scans.
SPEAKER_01: But the passive array has a persistent blind spot aft port.
SPEAKER_03: That's right.
SPEAKER_01: The Ghost Transponder, because there have been modifications to allow you to put in
SPEAKER_01: permanently linked transponders, it also allows someone to attempt to code a
SPEAKER_01: transponder on the fly.
SPEAKER_01: You have a plus one on all successes to attempt to disguise
SPEAKER_01: your ship's identity,
SPEAKER_01: but the way it does it is it pulls up registrations it has scanned before.
SPEAKER_01: So you might scan the Sky's sister ship and not realize that's what you're
SPEAKER_01: transmitting.
SPEAKER_00: What skills does it take to affect that, to try that?
SPEAKER_01: You could try to do it with a computer.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Because you're basically a photo program.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, cool.
SPEAKER_00: I'm not saying we're going to need to do that, but I'm not not saying that.
SPEAKER_01: And the thing is, most ships you can't at all, because the transponder is so deep
SPEAKER_01: inside the computer...
SPEAKER_01: You can't do it, but because they've ripped it apart to be able to put in
SPEAKER_01: the modifiers, you guys can try to hardwire and do it.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, I mean, obviously we'll flip through the CDs and see if there's one we like,
SPEAKER_00: but in case there's not...
SPEAKER_01: But here is another good one.
SPEAKER_01: Well-maintained.
SPEAKER_01: All maintenance costs are halved.
SPEAKER_01: Despite everything else, somebody loved this ship.
SPEAKER_01: The hull may be ancient and full of improvised modifications.
SPEAKER_01: All important machinery has been obsessively serviced.
SPEAKER_01: Wow, okay.
SPEAKER_00: This isn't the list of what is currently wrong with the ship.
SPEAKER_00: This is what could be wrong with the ship?
SPEAKER_01: These are all the ship quirks that are automatically there regardless of natural
SPEAKER_01: repairs.
SPEAKER_00: Gotcha. Okay, so these do currently exist. Is anybody making a list?
SPEAKER_00: I was going to paste it.
SPEAKER_00: Thank you, sir.
SPEAKER_02: But all these things can hypothet—well, not all of them, but 90% of these can be
SPEAKER_02: fixed with a substantial amount of money and time, hypothetically.
SPEAKER_01: I love the hypothetical word.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, we can go with the word hypothetical.
SPEAKER_01: The way the ship quirk mechanic really works, it is entirely up to the storyteller's
SPEAKER_01: prerogative if they can ever be removed without basically just building a new ship.
SPEAKER_01: I remember- This is just a boat.
SPEAKER_01: Just a boat. It's just an interesting boat.
SPEAKER_01: Jumping around in the ship.
SPEAKER_01: When you guys get a better ship, you guys are just going to put this in
SPEAKER_01: the cargo bay of the boat, of your better ship.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, this is not the end-all,
SPEAKER_01: be-all ship.
SPEAKER_02: That's beautiful that, I mean, like, sure, but, I mean, we're also, like, criminals,
SPEAKER_02: and maybe the Chronicle has the possibilities for a better ship, but we don't know
SPEAKER_02: that.
SPEAKER_02: Right.
SPEAKER_01: So it's only 30 times.
SPEAKER_00: But also, we do know that we're not keeping this ship, like, the idea is that
SPEAKER_00: this ship is where we live forever, because it's just an inter-systemary ship, and
SPEAKER_00: we have other things to deal with.
SPEAKER_00: This is a stopgap measure.
SPEAKER_01: Of course, Discord does not like me pasting this much text.
SPEAKER_00: This allows us to get to the other planets in system, though, which is a big
SPEAKER_00: plus.
SPEAKER_00: Once the engines have been, you know, cleaned up and modified, power has been topped
SPEAKER_00: off, and...
SPEAKER_00: A lot of those just standard maintenance.
SPEAKER_00: Just, you know, before we pilot anything, let me inspire you.
SPEAKER_01: You can really tell here who's for Scar had some character
SPEAKER_01: and who's didn't.
SPEAKER_02: I like how positive everyone else is. They're like, sure, we'll get a new ship.
SPEAKER_02: Why not? And I'm like, okay, you'll have a lot of faith in us.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. In main chats, I've put all those ship quirks.
SPEAKER_01: Now, I've also put it on a ship in Foundry.
SPEAKER_01: I am going to configure the ownership right now.
SPEAKER_01: Everyone can see this.
SPEAKER_01: So there's a ship called the Volante now on the actors.
SPEAKER_01: I've also put characters already on the crew, so you can roll directly from it.
SPEAKER_01: I have Laura on sensors, I have Jocelyn Steinbach on engineer, and I have Varian on
SPEAKER_01: being the pilot.
SPEAKER_03: Who's on jumping?
SPEAKER_02: There's no jump drive.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, so nobody.
SPEAKER_00: This is why we're not overly concerned with the ship.
SPEAKER_01: Who has astrogation higher than two?
SPEAKER_02: I have Jump Drive at 3, not including
SPEAKER_02: my numbers.
SPEAKER_01: I'm checking my astrogation right now, actually.
SPEAKER_02: You guys don't need astrogation.
SPEAKER_02: Because we don't have Jump Drive.
SPEAKER_02: No, I got it.
SPEAKER_02: I just thought he was like, well, who's good at it?
SPEAKER_02: And I'm like, I think a 3 not including modifiers is pretty good.
SPEAKER_00: Hey, I'm no good at it anyway, so it doesn't matter.
Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: If it's not combat, it's recon and drones.
SPEAKER_01: That's what Annette has.
SPEAKER_01: Right.
SPEAKER_01: Recon and drones.
SPEAKER_01: Now,
SPEAKER_01: you can go 5G.
SPEAKER_01: So it basically is from planet to planet is probably
SPEAKER_01: four to five hours a planet.
SPEAKER_01: And to get to gas giants, it's probably 18 to 20 hours.
SPEAKER_03: That's like napkin math.
SPEAKER_00: That's, like, are you saying planet to the very next planet?
SPEAKER_03: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: As I said, like, 5G is really not that fast, you know, system.
SPEAKER_03: Right.
SPEAKER_03: The old Harrier, you guys had 8G. Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: You're not taking things down.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, and the one weird thing, by the way, on the mechanics is it has a
SPEAKER_01: fuel scoop.
SPEAKER_03: But you use fuel for jumping.
SPEAKER_03: Well, to get a
SPEAKER_00: bigger ship bay, we can have it gather up the fuel for our jump-capable ship in
SPEAKER_00: the future.
SPEAKER_01: Exactly.
SPEAKER_00: Can I confirm something, Patrick?
SPEAKER_00: Yes. There are a couple of these things, Damage Thrusters and Asymmetric Drive.
SPEAKER_00: Those stack, correct?
SPEAKER_00: Um...
SPEAKER_00: So if we are in an evasive maneuver and need to do a pilot check, we
SPEAKER_00: get a minus one from damage thrusters and we get a minus one from asymmetric drive?
SPEAKER_03: Damage thrusters?
SPEAKER_03: Yes.
SPEAKER_03: That would be bad.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Theoretically, by the way, if you're going under,
SPEAKER_01: like, three Gs,
SPEAKER_01: Um, you only would be negative one.
SPEAKER_01: Right.
SPEAKER_01: You're only going to have to worry about the negative two when you guys are actually
SPEAKER_01: at, like,
SPEAKER_01: your full 5G.
SPEAKER_03: Mm-hmm.
SPEAKER_03: Um,
SPEAKER_03: and hell,
SPEAKER_01: you know, even asymmetric drive, it actually is only going to occur when you're
SPEAKER_01: dodging things.
SPEAKER_01: If you slowly build up speed, that one's not going to count.
SPEAKER_03: Right.
SPEAKER_00: I guess I'm thinking, oh, a system patrol boat is after us, and we are dodging
SPEAKER_00: and weaving through an asteroid field.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, absolutely.
SPEAKER_03: Yes.
SPEAKER_01: Stack on the penalties.
SPEAKER_03: I'm
SPEAKER_03: so glad we have an awesome pilot.
SPEAKER_01: Yes.
SPEAKER_01: No, like, honestly, you guys having Alan losing two off the roll is not going to
SPEAKER_01: kill you.
SPEAKER_00: He says that now. Right. Right.
SPEAKER_02: Someone should fool me. He's like, I meant hypothetically, not actually.
SPEAKER_01: I also put, if you guys are looking at the ship under notes, the very bottom
SPEAKER_01: is after you've paid to get it repaired with what you are selling and salvage,
SPEAKER_01: that's the level it's at then.
SPEAKER_01: So the hull is patched and pressured tight, but several repairs are visual
SPEAKER_01: temporarily with mismatched plating and sealant around all breaches.
SPEAKER_01: Fuel tanks have been flushed and filled. You have enough fuel for normal operations.
SPEAKER_01: Power is unreliable during startup. You'll need several attempts before the power
SPEAKER_01: plant settles into a stable cycle.
SPEAKER_01: The drives are functional
SPEAKER_01: with the damage, quirk, and vibration issues.
SPEAKER_01: Life support is operational but pleasant.
SPEAKER_01: Filters and ducting are clean rather than replaced.
SPEAKER_01: The interior is still heavily water-damaged.
SPEAKER_01: Upholstery, insulation, wall panels, and storage compartments remain damp or
SPEAKER_01: stained.
SPEAKER_01: There's a persistent mixture of seawater, mildew, hydraulic fluid, ozone, and old
SPEAKER_01: machinery.
SPEAKER_01: This will get worse as the ship warms up.
SPEAKER_01: Gross.
SPEAKER_01: Electronics. Most critical systems work, but the connectors and wireies have massive
SPEAKER_01: corrosive damage. Random faults will be common.
SPEAKER_01: Sensors are operational with the existing damage sensor penalty.
SPEAKER_01: The cargo areas are usable, but some compartments still have standing moisture and
SPEAKER_01: corrosion.
SPEAKER_01: The crew spaces are habitable barely. The mattresses and soft furnishings should
SPEAKER_01: probably just be thrown away.
SPEAKER_01: Overall, it is space-worthy with a legal certification
SPEAKER_01: and deeply unpleasant to live aboard, but you can definitely get from point A to
SPEAKER_01: point B.
SPEAKER_00: That deeply unpleasant, I can't wait.
SPEAKER_01: Maybe we should just go to prison, I think, guys.
SPEAKER_01: I think that might be more pleasant.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, a Jordanian prison does sound quite pleasant, you know?
SPEAKER_01: Maybe you'll have a prison-filled day, like a TransStar day.
SPEAKER_00: Prison Star day.
SPEAKER_00: So Victor will put on comms out to teams that, does anybody know about salvage
SPEAKER_00: rights?
SPEAKER_00: Because if we show up at the TransStar dock in this ship while we are TransStar
SPEAKER_00: employees, Does that mean Transtar owns it?
SPEAKER_00: How do we ensure that we own this ship?
SPEAKER_03: That's a good question.
SPEAKER_03: Is that a broker? Is that like an admin?
SPEAKER_01: I
SPEAKER_01: have two trains of thought. One,
SPEAKER_01: Zoi was a builder, and one of his careers was Salvager, but I don't have
SPEAKER_01: any...
SPEAKER_01: You were always an independent salvager. You never had to work for a megacorp.
SPEAKER_01: So you're like, when I was a kid, we just would pick up whatever we found.
SPEAKER_01: But the legality of it on Jordanian planet will be an advocate role, which I don't
SPEAKER_01: know if any player does.
SPEAKER_00: I do.
SPEAKER_01: You do? I have it at one.
SPEAKER_01: Roll that bean footage.
SPEAKER_01: Oh,
SPEAKER_02: Laura, go.
SPEAKER_01: Go, Laura, go!
SPEAKER_00: Be inspired! Go, Laura, go! Leadership, yay!
SPEAKER_00: Like, for real? Should I put inspired? Or is that...
SPEAKER_00: Can I leadership her? Or can you leadership her?
SPEAKER_01: Yes, you can leadership her, especially since you sang the song.
SPEAKER_02: He's like, please don't sing any songs. I'm feeling very inspired.
SPEAKER_02: He's like, I'm almost there. Five more minutes.
SPEAKER_00: This is his leadership song. We rock it.
SPEAKER_01: No, like, Isaac's like, no singing, Daddy. No singing.
SPEAKER_01: I know.
SPEAKER_00: He says that, though, when you're not singing.
SPEAKER_00: You're just like, what voices are you hearing, buddy?
SPEAKER_01: Okay. So, yes, you do have a boon, Laura.
SPEAKER_00: All right. Cool. All right. Here we go, then.
SPEAKER_03: Woo!
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So, here's the easiest way to get around it.
SPEAKER_01: Almost all of you join TransStar under fake identities.
SPEAKER_00: No, we didn't. I mean, not to just throw a wrench in that one, but we
SPEAKER_00: tried.
SPEAKER_00: And they're like, no, we know who you are.
SPEAKER_00: The one lady was like, yeah, I killed my husband.
SPEAKER_01: Well, you could sign it up in anyone's name and say you're picking it up for
SPEAKER_01: them.
SPEAKER_03: Prove it.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, so make a fake identity for
SPEAKER_03: the ownership paperwork.
SPEAKER_01: Right. Yeah. Prove it.
SPEAKER_01: And also, with that Advocate Six, I would say that
SPEAKER_01: you can put it in the name of any of your million and one fucking contacts.
SPEAKER_00: I do like that.
SPEAKER_01: And then the moment you're no longer having to try and start A, write it back
SPEAKER_01: to you.
SPEAKER_01: The good news is, is because it's so crappy, no
SPEAKER_02: one's going to want to try and steal it from us.
SPEAKER_01: I do want to know, as crappy as this is, it's still worth, like, probably $2.5
SPEAKER_01: million.
SPEAKER_01: I hear that.
SPEAKER_01: It still smells.
SPEAKER_03: For farts, if nothing else. It smells like cash.
SPEAKER_03: You guys have to, like...
SPEAKER_03: You have to think of...
SPEAKER_01: This is why everyone's first score should be a piece of shit.
SPEAKER_01: They would understand what's going on here much better.
SPEAKER_02: I mean, listen, my first car was, like,
SPEAKER_02: I think 18 years old, but it didn't smell terribly.
SPEAKER_01: You guys should think of this more like Storage Wars.
SPEAKER_00: Did it have working brakes? Was there plumbing pipes in the engine welded into it?
SPEAKER_02: It did have working brakes.
SPEAKER_00: There were pipes to the car also in the storage unit.
SPEAKER_00: They just weren't installed in the car.
SPEAKER_01: The fact that Varian can actually theoretically get this to orbit is an amazing deal
SPEAKER_01: for you guys.
SPEAKER_01: Sounds good. Do I make a roll or
SPEAKER_00: not yet?
SPEAKER_01: Well, you could definitely try to take off.
SPEAKER_01: It still has holes in it.
SPEAKER_00: We'll probably have some more repairing to do first.
SPEAKER_00: Can you do some mechanic checks?
SPEAKER_00: Like different people mechanic fixing different parts?
SPEAKER_01: Without a mechanic check, you can see the holes.
SPEAKER_00: No, I mean, like, to fix it. I
SPEAKER_00: think we need supplies.
SPEAKER_01: Right. Like, you need chip plating, and you need venting, and you would need...
SPEAKER_01: Like, you guys have the stuff to, like, patch up a hole.
SPEAKER_01: You don't have the stuff to actually make this able to handle a
SPEAKER_01: leaving a planet orbit kind of level of pressures and heats.
SPEAKER_01: So...
SPEAKER_01: I'm happy if you guys are interested in hand-waving, you sell the salvage, you get
SPEAKER_01: it to usable state.
SPEAKER_01: Do you guys just want to do that?
SPEAKER_00: I would like to do that just because, yeah, Stockbroker, the video game, is
SPEAKER_00: not exactly my favorite.
SPEAKER_00: But I know that there are certain people who do enjoy that, and I don't want
SPEAKER_00: to take that from them if they want to explore that.
SPEAKER_00: I mean, it's the reason I didn't play. I'm happy to have it hand-waved.
SPEAKER_01: There are going to be plenty of other times where we're going to have actual
SPEAKER_01: situations.
SPEAKER_01: I don't want to necessarily go into the aspect of how damaged your
SPEAKER_01: cargo is,
SPEAKER_01: since it has been underwater literally for 110 years.
SPEAKER_01: Right. Look, it's vintage.
SPEAKER_01: Vintage.
SPEAKER_01: Vaulted. Vaulted.
SPEAKER_01: So,
SPEAKER_01: I would let anyone... I'm going to do...
SPEAKER_01: We'll do it this way. I'm going to do a 1d6 roll, and this is how
SPEAKER_01: many days it's going to take them to repair it after you've sold them the salvage.
SPEAKER_03: Take it.
SPEAKER_03: D6.
SPEAKER_03: It'll all be done in two days.
SPEAKER_03: That's pretty great.
SPEAKER_01: That's pretty fast.
SPEAKER_00: Since we have a time limit.
SPEAKER_01: Well, they don't want to be in any longer than they have to, because it smells.
SPEAKER_01: So, you guys are, you guys have,
SPEAKER_01: Varin can fly it sub-orbitally, like basically skimming it off the water to the
SPEAKER_01: repair place.
SPEAKER_01: They ask for your paperwork. Emma gives the paperwork of, oh, you know, there was
SPEAKER_01: someone shipped that sunk. Here's the paperwork.
SPEAKER_01: You know, there's all this cargo. If you take the cargo and repair to at least
SPEAKER_01: make it orbit-worthy, what's the kind of deal?
SPEAKER_01: He basically says, we can do it. We can definitely get it there.
SPEAKER_01: But it's not going to win any beauty contests.
SPEAKER_01: And you might want to...
SPEAKER_01: He's like, I'll throw in one of those little...
SPEAKER_01: Air freshener trees.
SPEAKER_00: I was thinking that exact same thing.
SPEAKER_02: We want a thousand.
SPEAKER_01: Can we just have one implanted into my nose?
SPEAKER_03: That's probably cheaper.
SPEAKER_01: And...
SPEAKER_01: So you are now back on, let's actually go to the Jordanian City.
SPEAKER_01: This is your weekend by the member because it did take you a week to kind
SPEAKER_01: of do all the other pieces that you had done.
SPEAKER_01: Let's go to activate the capital of Jordan.
SPEAKER_01: So
SPEAKER_01: all of that was taken to the
SPEAKER_01: Naval Annex
SPEAKER_01: and they're repairing it in the Naval Annex.
SPEAKER_01: You guys do have the password to unlock the pad, but I don't know if you
SPEAKER_01: guys want to do that here or do that somewhere else.
SPEAKER_03: You do have
SPEAKER_03: freedom to go wherever you want. Well, I would definitely feel more
SPEAKER_00: comfortable unlocking it here in the Trinstar area where the local cops just
SPEAKER_00: can't show up.
SPEAKER_00: But here or outer space is
SPEAKER_03: kind of my two thoughts.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, I concur with that. I don't want to go out into the general population with
SPEAKER_00: things because I feel like that's, even though we're wearing TransStar uniforms,
SPEAKER_00: that's still more of a risk than I'm kind of willing to take
SPEAKER_00: to clear my name because they're already disappearing people.
SPEAKER_01: Do you guys want to go to your fancy housing in Transtar?
SPEAKER_00: Yes.
SPEAKER_00: I would also, yes.
SPEAKER_00: Fancy housing, fancy coffee.
SPEAKER_02: When we leave the ship, are we smelly or are we fine?
SPEAKER_01: I would say that you decide to go have an ozone shower in the fancy housing.
SPEAKER_01: You're probably smelly because on top of that, you've been on a stinky sub for a
SPEAKER_01: week.
SPEAKER_01: Stinky.
SPEAKER_03: Submariners are not known for their incredible hygiene.
SPEAKER_03: All right.
SPEAKER_00: Who's got the skills to operate the pad?
SPEAKER_00: That's not exactly where my strengths lie.
SPEAKER_00: Operate what?
SPEAKER_03: The pad.
SPEAKER_03: No one understands what you mean.
SPEAKER_03: That's me and Emily. Yeah, hold
SPEAKER_03: on.
SPEAKER_02: I don't think we have a hacker extraordinaire, which is unfortunate.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, I know how to use computers.
SPEAKER_00: We can go anywhere without
SPEAKER_00: being stopped?
SPEAKER_01: Well, you're in TransStar uniforms, so people are going to think you're TransStar
SPEAKER_01: employees. If you start acting like criminals or go be caught on the news, then
SPEAKER_01: they'll detain you.
SPEAKER_00: I have a question. Yep.
SPEAKER_00: Is getting,
SPEAKER_00: like, books from the university or,
SPEAKER_03: like,
SPEAKER_03: checking out books
SPEAKER_00: while in my TransStar uniform or ID
SPEAKER_03: viable?
SPEAKER_01: It kind of depends on the books.
SPEAKER_01: Can you kind of describe a little bit of what book you're trying to get?
SPEAKER_01: If you're trying to get like
SPEAKER_01: the Secret Mysteries of Social Solidarity, probably not.
SPEAKER_01: If you're trying to get like Biology 101, you can do that from your pad.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, like from the pad?
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, like it depends on what you're looking for.
SPEAKER_03: Is there any security on it?
SPEAKER_00: Like, I'm thinking, like, to get a book on,
SPEAKER_00: like, a how-to book on, like, life support or power,
SPEAKER_00: you know?
SPEAKER_01: You easily can get that.
SPEAKER_01: You can easily get, you can fill your pad up with basic ship knowledges.
SPEAKER_00: And, like, potentially use it and learn it during space time.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Mm-hmm.
SPEAKER_01: So there's normally a thing called the library, which your thing does not have.
SPEAKER_01: So if you have a library, the idea is you have every book you could possibly
SPEAKER_01: need.
SPEAKER_01: You're basically saying the book that I'm attempting to work on, I am downloading
SPEAKER_01: while we're on planet.
SPEAKER_03: That's fine.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Well, yeah, why not, like, buy every book, basically, on the—you know what I mean?
SPEAKER_00: On the skills list, and then—
SPEAKER_01: Well, I would—the thing is, I'll let you buy two without having a library.
SPEAKER_01: Ah, okay.
SPEAKER_00: Plus, they cost money.
SPEAKER_01: No. Oh.
SPEAKER_01: They don't. It's a space issue.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, okay. The idea is libraries are able to hold, basically— Like a
SPEAKER_01: Wikipedia level of knowledge, while
SPEAKER_01: your little pad is basically getting
SPEAKER_01: idiot's guide to life support.
SPEAKER_01: I'm going to let you have enough that you guys can get the bonus for education
SPEAKER_01: on one or two skills until you guys get a full library.
SPEAKER_01: Because the idea is when you finish that, you would need the next book and the
SPEAKER_01: next book and the next book. And so that's why they don't list the individual books
SPEAKER_01: you need.
SPEAKER_01: And they just all lock it into you. You guys spend points on having a powered
SPEAKER_01: library on a ship.
SPEAKER_01: And we only have one, one pad.
SPEAKER_01: Well, you have the pad of Mercers, which is locked right now.
SPEAKER_01: Uh-huh. Most of you would have, like, a generic-level iPhone.
SPEAKER_01: So I have no problem with you guys having one or two educational books on there.
SPEAKER_01: You're focusing on a particular skill.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Going off of that, it does strike me that having the manuals for the shipboat make
SPEAKER_00: a model that we've got, probably not a bad idea to have in case it breaks
SPEAKER_00: down between planes.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah. Yeah.
SPEAKER_03: I like that idea.
Yeah.
SPEAKER_03: It's basically your mechanics level for it.
SPEAKER_03: And so this ship does have a...
SPEAKER_03: Uh-huh.
SPEAKER_03: Sorry about that.
SPEAKER_03: I didn't mean to interrupt.
SPEAKER_00: No, go ahead.
SPEAKER_00: So I was thinking, does this ship have a life support or a power drive?
SPEAKER_00: Yep.
SPEAKER_01: The only thing that's really missing is a jump drive.
SPEAKER_01: It has bare-bones aspects of every other piece of a ship you need.
SPEAKER_01: By the way, there's even a turret to put a gun on it, but there's just
SPEAKER_01: no gun on it.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: That's what we have a robot for. I know.
SPEAKER_03: It's funny.
SPEAKER_01: Right on the whole and shoot it.
SPEAKER_01: Right?
SPEAKER_01: Oh, my God. I'm, like, saying, like, you know, I know it looks like a turret
SPEAKER_01: mount. It's actually a robot seat.
SPEAKER_00: So now just bolt your legs onto
SPEAKER_03: this and...
SPEAKER_00: Are we uploading the schematics of the ship as one of the things that we can
SPEAKER_00: upload?
SPEAKER_00: Or is that just a given?
SPEAKER_01: I would say is that a mechanics.
SPEAKER_01: If someone wants to basically have a how-do-I-learn-mechanics
SPEAKER_01: skill, that is the schematics of the ship.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. It's the schematics of the ship when it was new, but we all know this
SPEAKER_01: thing has
SPEAKER_01: Hundreds of years of patches and alterations on it.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, so yeah, so I thought people meant, like, the schematics of the current ship for
SPEAKER_02: when we were fixing it so you could, like, pull up stuff.
SPEAKER_03: That's what I thought they meant.
SPEAKER_01: You've got to where it's new.
SPEAKER_01: No one would know exactly the schematics of the ship right now.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Or
SPEAKER_00: Scotty making quick patches and keeping things running for a long time.
SPEAKER_02: Well, I like that.
SPEAKER_01: I think I'm going to run a
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, I was taking it kind of like a Han and Chewie with like, hey, you
SPEAKER_01: know, we really need to jump right now and you're deciding to rewire something in
SPEAKER_01: the middle of a gunfight.
SPEAKER_00: I have a question. You just growl at it and it works.
SPEAKER_02: If I was interested in trying to get
SPEAKER_02: like a chip implanted in my brain, how long would that take?
SPEAKER_02: Is that like an afternoon thing or is that like
SPEAKER_02: What's the downtime? How
SPEAKER_02: complicated is it?
SPEAKER_01: Well, first, it's a fair amount of money, which I don't know if you have.
SPEAKER_01: I probably don't know.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. So when we have the money, we can begin to address the time.
SPEAKER_01: The thing is, they would also register you based on your genetics, and then that
SPEAKER_01: would come up as you a criminal.
SPEAKER_01: So you have a few barriers for that right now.
SPEAKER_02: Fair enough. Thank you.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, you could try to do it through the Underworld, guys, if you got yourself a
SPEAKER_01: bag of cash.
SPEAKER_01: And they could they could wire that up for you probably in a day if you
SPEAKER_01: had enough money.
SPEAKER_03: Thanks.
SPEAKER_01: Back to the original bit, who was going to actually turn on Mercer's data pad and
SPEAKER_01: actually put in the code?
SPEAKER_01: And how about Soy and Emily work on that together?
SPEAKER_00: It is still Emma.
SPEAKER_01: Emma? Oh, that's what I was thinking as Emily.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, no worries. Emily is my sister's middle name, so I'm kind of like, well, that
SPEAKER_00: wouldn't be too bad. Oh, okay, okay.
SPEAKER_00: I'd like to be present for that. Okay.
SPEAKER_02: So, who is physically touching it?
SPEAKER_00: Well, I have computers one.
SPEAKER_02: That sounds like a suspicious thing to ask, but oh.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Then,
SPEAKER_00: yeah, I think you should do it. Yeah, you should probably touch it.
SPEAKER_00: Would you like to be inspired?
SPEAKER_00: Because I think, with your little monkey fingers, you're going to touch it better
SPEAKER_00: than any chimp could ever touch.
SPEAKER_00: You're going to get a song?
SPEAKER_00: You can stroke it, that keyboard. You're going to sing Code Monkey.
SPEAKER_03: I love
SPEAKER_00: the song. That would be funny.
SPEAKER_00: When you think about it, you touch that pad, whoa!
SPEAKER_03: There we go.
SPEAKER_03: Okay, you definitely get your boon.
SPEAKER_03: Roll your computers.
SPEAKER_03: It picks up and says,
SPEAKER_01: Hello, Senator Mercer.
SPEAKER_01: Authentication accepted.
SPEAKER_03: How can I assist you today?
SPEAKER_03: Let's see.
SPEAKER_00: To query its backlogs of communications.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, I was trying to think of what to have because I doubt he has a
SPEAKER_01: file just labeled Grand Conspiracy.
SPEAKER_01: What was the name
SPEAKER_00: of that organization?
SPEAKER_01: Well, you can ask him the last three documents that have been edited.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, let's do that.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: He says first was a ticket bought off space.
SPEAKER_01: The ticket has expired, but our registry shows that it was used.
SPEAKER_01: The thing after that was we had
SPEAKER_01: pre-writing of your speech that you were going to give to the committee,
SPEAKER_01: and the other document you wrote in there was Research Topics.
SPEAKER_03: Let's look at Research Topics. I wrote those last two.
SPEAKER_00: Where was the destination of the flight that was apparently used?
SPEAKER_01: It was going to the planet called Provenance in the Jordanian system.
SPEAKER_01: It is a planet one closer to the sun from where you are.
SPEAKER_02: So Damien's not your character's name. Zoi is the one who's
SPEAKER_01: currently using it?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, I imagine everyone and their mother, though, is, like, leaning over this
SPEAKER_01: three-foot-tall monkey.
SPEAKER_02: I'm standing over in the corner, but I'm like, does this mean that Zoe is going
SPEAKER_02: to always have to be the person who uses it?
SPEAKER_02: Like, moving forward?
SPEAKER_02: Just wondering.
SPEAKER_00: Imagine whoever puts the code in next would be the person using it.
SPEAKER_02: I don't know. I just don't know if it, like, locks out other people or, you
SPEAKER_02: know, if it only recognizes specific people.
SPEAKER_02: I'm just curious.
SPEAKER_01: I'd be happy to answer that with a computer rule, Josh.
SPEAKER_02: I barely understand how to use computers, but sure.
SPEAKER_01: That's what I'm saying.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, someone else should roll this. It's your question, Josh.
SPEAKER_02: It's your question.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, I'm going to roll it with a zero. This sounds like a great idea.
SPEAKER_02: Nobody else wants to.
SPEAKER_03: I love it. That was a great roll. Yeah.
SPEAKER_03: That's an amazing role, Josh.
SPEAKER_03: It surprisingly was.
SPEAKER_01: So, no, anyone who puts in the code will theoretically be able to have access to
SPEAKER_01: it within a period of time.
SPEAKER_01: Now, let me kind of break a little bit more data down because you've got an
SPEAKER_01: amazing role.
SPEAKER_01: This sure sounds like an AI, right?
SPEAKER_01: Yes.
SPEAKER_01: It's linking to a governmental AI that has siloed
SPEAKER_01: sections for people in political power.
SPEAKER_01: Once it has the data that the clone of Mercer has left Planet,
SPEAKER_01: it will seal this permanently.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, that also then means that the person, well,
SPEAKER_00: I need to be told this, I guess.
SPEAKER_00: But if the person who left the planet...
SPEAKER_02: Listen, guys, I really barely understand anything about computers, but I have a very
SPEAKER_02: good feeling, and then continue, Patrick.
SPEAKER_02: And this is what I'm saying.
SPEAKER_01: It doesn't seem that there's a lot of intentional feedback to the Senate AI.
SPEAKER_01: It only is when you individually put in data, or there will be a timestamp every
SPEAKER_01: time you look at something.
SPEAKER_01: But they have no way of knowing it's not the Mercer clone.
SPEAKER_01: Because you're going fully with the code of the Mercer clone.
SPEAKER_01: But once the Mercer clone is a registered person in airspace, it will seal his
SPEAKER_01: senatorial account because he's no longer a senator.
SPEAKER_00: But it means that the person who took the flight was not
SPEAKER_00: recognized as Mercer.
SPEAKER_01: Absolutely. He bought a sticker for someone else.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, okay.
SPEAKER_00: I thought he bought a ticket for himself and someone else took his flight.
SPEAKER_01: Nope, he bought a ticket for someone else to
SPEAKER_03: go to Providence.
SPEAKER_03: Is someone speaking that I can't
SPEAKER_03: answer? It does feel like that, but I'm muted, so it's not me.
SPEAKER_03: I love how Josh phrased that, by the way.
SPEAKER_01: Because if Josh was muted,
SPEAKER_03: that would be the funniest thing to say.
SPEAKER_03: So I love you,
SPEAKER_03: Josh. Love you too, man.
SPEAKER_03: So
SPEAKER_03: what do you guys want to investigate? You guys have the flight, you guys have the
SPEAKER_03: speech, and you guys have his research notes.
SPEAKER_00: Are those research notes
SPEAKER_00: in a format that we could maybe send to our friendly officer?
SPEAKER_00: See if he can continue digging on his end?
SPEAKER_00: I guess we should read them first.
SPEAKER_00: I have my personal computer out, and I am making notes of what his notes are.
SPEAKER_01: I would say, like, while it's on the screen, you guys could, like, take photos with
SPEAKER_01: a phone so you don't actually even have a file transfer record.
SPEAKER_03: I like it.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: So
SPEAKER_03: here is the basic
SPEAKER_01: kind of pathway of the notes.
SPEAKER_01: First,
SPEAKER_01: this started about two and a half years ago.
SPEAKER_01: And what happened was there was
SPEAKER_01: A chancellor whose
SPEAKER_01: son did a registration to get into a university inside Soleimani space, like a
SPEAKER_01: Harvard-level university.
SPEAKER_03: And his
SPEAKER_03: genetic code came back unacceptable.
SPEAKER_01: So that chancellor asked Mercer as the head of genetics to investigate
SPEAKER_01: How this could happen because
SPEAKER_03: he was basically
SPEAKER_03: CRISPR born from two perfect Selimani.
SPEAKER_03: And so Mercer begins to investigate this
SPEAKER_01: and he's like, yeah,
SPEAKER_01: if you have a potato and a potato, you get a potato.
SPEAKER_01: You don't get a potato and a potato and it makes a garlic.
SPEAKER_01: And so he begins to start realizing that
SPEAKER_01: certain people,
SPEAKER_01: while undergoing normal medical procedures,
SPEAKER_01: are being affected by something that is
SPEAKER_03: changing their genetic code.
SPEAKER_03: So that's kind of stage one.
SPEAKER_01: And he's like,
SPEAKER_01: okay, I have to prove this then.
SPEAKER_01: So
SPEAKER_01: he knows that
SPEAKER_01: the president of Jardin
SPEAKER_01: was going to have a son be born.
SPEAKER_01: So as soon as the son was born, because he was like a friend of the
SPEAKER_01: family, he was there.
SPEAKER_01: And he took a physical genetic sample of the child.
SPEAKER_01: And then he was going to wait two years,
SPEAKER_01: and then he was going to take a new physical genetic sample of the child to
SPEAKER_01: show that they're changing the kids or the adults or the people.
SPEAKER_01: And he had other proofs that they were.
SPEAKER_01: It is...
SPEAKER_00: Can I have a clarification?
SPEAKER_00: Because you made it sound like they were already born with this change.
SPEAKER_00: You're saying that, like, something is...
SPEAKER_00: Actively changing them as they're going along?
SPEAKER_03: Yes.
SPEAKER_03: That's what he's discovering.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Thank you. I just needed that clarification.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: And what he begins to believe
SPEAKER_01: is people are gradually changing. Oh, let's also give this one key piece of data
SPEAKER_01: before I move on.
SPEAKER_01: It's not enough of a change that the quick sensors or the quick blood tests are
SPEAKER_01: going to find it.
SPEAKER_01: It only comes up when you're doing a high-level sequence, which is only done when
SPEAKER_01: you need truly, like, you're going from, you're going to an elected office, or
SPEAKER_01: you're going to become a military commander.
SPEAKER_01: These are not things, they don't fully sequence you for small things like, hey, can
SPEAKER_01: I get into a building?
SPEAKER_02: This is basically like in Foundation, where Cleon's DNA is being changed, and no
SPEAKER_02: one else can tell, but But the people in charge of Purity know that he's no
SPEAKER_02: longer a pure Cleon.
SPEAKER_01: Mix that with Gattaca's, like, testing every minute, and the testing every minute's
SPEAKER_01: not picking up.
SPEAKER_01: Fair enough.
SPEAKER_01: By the way, Gattaca's one of my favorite movies ever.
SPEAKER_01: It has the Buffonzo badge of Purity.
SPEAKER_01: That's an awesome badge of Purity, by
SPEAKER_03: the way. It is.
SPEAKER_03: Gets you on the spaceship.
SPEAKER_03: So
SPEAKER_03: he believes that this is actually being prepared for blackmail.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, interesting. Okay. Yeah, I can see how the ramifications of that.
SPEAKER_01: People who are so obsessed with perfect genetic purity, who already are in these
SPEAKER_01: incredibly high political positions or military positions, there's going to be a
SPEAKER_01: moment where they're going to realize their kids' DNA is not with it.
SPEAKER_01: He was basically going to say,
SPEAKER_01: We can't trust the continuing genetic aspects of full sequencing.
SPEAKER_01: We only contest a recorded record of birth because he feels there are
SPEAKER_03: people here manipulating.
SPEAKER_03: So take that one big chunk.
SPEAKER_01: That was the primary part of his research.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Wow. Yes.
SPEAKER_01: Please ask. Continue.
SPEAKER_01: Please, please, please ask.
SPEAKER_02: Originally, we found out that there was a Psyker component to some of this.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, that's the next piece.
SPEAKER_01: I'll just go straight to that. Okay, so you got it.
SPEAKER_01: So, as he's beginning to try to research on who could possibly make these
SPEAKER_01: CRISPR-level alterations on people without them noticing,
SPEAKER_01: he begins to find the research that was done that you guys picked up of a
SPEAKER_01: group of people trying to
SPEAKER_01: create Psykers.
SPEAKER_01: And what this group has basically discovered, as far as he can tell,
SPEAKER_03: is by hard
SPEAKER_03: cloning known psykers into children,
SPEAKER_01: they can basically
SPEAKER_01: consistently make a one out of
SPEAKER_03: six of the clones is going to likely be a psyker themselves.
SPEAKER_03: Mm.
SPEAKER_03: They're able to Kind of make psychers.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah. And choose who becomes a psycher.
SPEAKER_03: Well, roughly.
SPEAKER_01: What the psychers have created is a new psychic power
SPEAKER_01: that allows them basically to, through incredible effort, to mentally crisper
SPEAKER_01: another person's body.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, like micromanipulation.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: And they do it kind of in a twisted, cancerous way.
SPEAKER_01: They basically go, hey, those white blood cells are going to start changing a
SPEAKER_01: bit of your bone marrow.
SPEAKER_01: And as your bone marrow begins to replace the rest of your cells,
SPEAKER_01: eventually you're going to have 30% to 40% of you as this alteration.
SPEAKER_01: And within seven years, all of you will be that alteration.
SPEAKER_03: Can I ask an out-of-quest character question?
SPEAKER_03: Yeah.
SPEAKER_02: Are we at all interested in playing up, you know, issues of racial purity, which is
SPEAKER_02: kind of central to this?
SPEAKER_02: Or is that going to be unpleasant to people and we want to skip that?
SPEAKER_01: I think
SPEAKER_01: a concept of people believing that they are racially pure is a key piece that we're
SPEAKER_01: going to be talking about. We're losing what they are.
SPEAKER_01: The idea of them being pure humanoid is going to be a very concept thing versus
SPEAKER_01: them being
SPEAKER_02: Because I could understand characters being highly offended, like that basically
SPEAKER_02: the purity of the Soleimani people is basically being destroyed by these psychers
SPEAKER_02: and like they're kind of something that needs to be destroyed and rooted out.
SPEAKER_02: It's like a very insidious plot.
SPEAKER_02: But I could also understand players being like, I don't give a fuck, like it's all
SPEAKER_02: about like just clearing us and whatever.
SPEAKER_02: And some people would find that to be unpleasant and I just kind of want to
SPEAKER_02: take a tone of the room.
SPEAKER_02: And I have no interest in playing something that's going to be unpleasant to
SPEAKER_02: players,
SPEAKER_02: actually.
SPEAKER_00: Well, I thought that we've covered this before,
SPEAKER_00: but we do have a different
SPEAKER_00: makeup, I guess. Because it was very important to Peter's character.
SPEAKER_00: No one is speaking up, so I think we're good.
SPEAKER_03: Wait, so Laura...
SPEAKER_03: I'm hearing...
SPEAKER_03: Paul, did you not hear Laura?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, I was like, oh no, am I still muted?
SPEAKER_03: No, I heard you, Laura.
SPEAKER_02: I can't hear Laura for some reason. I don't think he could hear you.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, yeah, a little bit where she just...
SPEAKER_02: I'm going to disconnect and reconnect also. I just think it's getting...
SPEAKER_00: Oh, okay.
SPEAKER_02: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: We're going to have Laura talk. Can you give us a one, two, three?
SPEAKER_00: One, two, three?
SPEAKER_01: Josh, you heard that?
SPEAKER_01: Yes, I did.
SPEAKER_03: Okay, Laura, can I have another one? I can hear you.
SPEAKER_00: One, two, three.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, you heard that?
SPEAKER_03: Colb, you heard that?
SPEAKER_03: I heard you.
SPEAKER_00: I didn't hear anyone else.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. That's weird. You must have right-clicked and muted Laura.
SPEAKER_01: It's the only answer to what we just seen.
SPEAKER_00: I don't think he was back in the chat yet when Laura said her one, two,
SPEAKER_00: three.
SPEAKER_00: Laura, say one, two, three.
SPEAKER_00: One, two, three.
SPEAKER_00: I hear you.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Okay. Awesome.
SPEAKER_03: Go, Laura.
SPEAKER_00: So...
SPEAKER_01: Where I think Laura was going is Peter's character was a key concept of this genetic
SPEAKER_01: purity.
SPEAKER_01: But Peter's not here right now, so...
SPEAKER_02: I mean, my character is also pretty pure, but, like, I'm fine to, like, drop it.
SPEAKER_02: I just wanted to know if that's, like, an interesting thing for Rabbit Hole or if
SPEAKER_02: we're like, we don't give a fuck. Like, that's kind of what
SPEAKER_00: I want. Well, I feel like it's... Go ahead.
SPEAKER_01: Does anyone not want to play it?
SPEAKER_01: We're asking here for the X card, and if people do not want to play this.
SPEAKER_00: I'm a pure Soleimani. I think most of us are.
SPEAKER_00: I've been trying to play it in a cool,
SPEAKER_00: low-key fashion, but not really low-key, I guess, because I do talk about Monkey Boy
SPEAKER_03: a lot. My character
SPEAKER_00: is a pure Soleimani, but I don't think I'm on the
SPEAKER_00: Praying with the, we is the master race.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so, the way I understand it, and what I think people are concerned about,
SPEAKER_01: like, in our culture, when we talk about, like, genetic purity, it's
SPEAKER_00: very much
SPEAKER_00: a thing races do, right?
SPEAKER_00: The Somali version, they don't think of it as, like, that way.
SPEAKER_00: They think about just being the best that they can be, right?
SPEAKER_01: They do think they are chosen people.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: They do feel that there is a certain genetic aspect of them to be the most
SPEAKER_01: populous thing in the stars.
SPEAKER_03: They do feel there's some type of a manifest destiny.
SPEAKER_03: I don't want to cloud those over.
SPEAKER_01: Do they feel that every other race needs to be eliminated?
SPEAKER_01: No, they don't.
SPEAKER_01: Do they feel that they're going to put everyone in concentration camps and gas them
SPEAKER_01: because it's cheaper than a bullet? No.
SPEAKER_01: They absolutely feel that just as time progresses, they're like, let's look at the
SPEAKER_01: last 50,000 years of history and so many humans have stretched farther than any
SPEAKER_01: other races
SPEAKER_03: that has ever existed.
SPEAKER_00: It's a very 19th, 18th century view of it.
SPEAKER_00: They're the best, so they should lead, and our leading will eventually
SPEAKER_00: make everyone at least almost as good as us.
SPEAKER_01: I will also put this for people who are feeling uncomfortable about the piece of it.
SPEAKER_01: What they've basically talked about is it can't be trusted anymore.
SPEAKER_01: So on both sides of it, even if you feel that's the greatest thing ever, that
SPEAKER_01: like, hey, you know, Soleimani are important, what you basically heard from Mercer
SPEAKER_01: is the purity of the Soleimani race is no longer pure.
SPEAKER_01: We can't trust it. We have to either stop this taint of it or just move
SPEAKER_01: on.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, because I feel like to ignore it is to kind of take away from the
SPEAKER_00: setting, but we don't have to like,
SPEAKER_00: I don't know if anyone saw that Annie wrote something in the chat.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, and I just wanted to add it on it.
SPEAKER_00: Sorry, I thought you didn't want to speak.
SPEAKER_00: Sorry, go ahead.
SPEAKER_00: No, I didn't want to speak over anyone, but I wanted to make sure my thoughts
SPEAKER_00: got put down.
SPEAKER_00: But
SPEAKER_00: I think that in settings like this where it's fiction and we're kind of exploring
SPEAKER_00: ideas and it gives us something to
SPEAKER_01: have our players chew on what our characters are mulling through is a fun layer of
SPEAKER_01: distinction,
SPEAKER_00: especially in a fictional setting. And then we can all say, well, OK, that does have
SPEAKER_00: parallels to real life.
SPEAKER_00: You're right. If anybody is having trouble with those layers and
SPEAKER_00: they're too close to the heat, then that's a good X card play.
SPEAKER_00: But
SPEAKER_00: me personally, I've got enough layers that I feel comfortable talking about this
SPEAKER_00: without it
SPEAKER_00: accidentally
SPEAKER_00: turning into a discussion about real politics or real
SPEAKER_00: ideologies.
SPEAKER_01: I would like to also bring up one other kind of weird parallel just in the
SPEAKER_01: greater Traveler universe that I know the pirate players got to experience.
SPEAKER_01: The ancients, the actual precursor race that did all these major things that
SPEAKER_01: affected the world,
SPEAKER_01: their basic Neanderthal descendants are one of the prime races of the Traveler
SPEAKER_01: universe.
SPEAKER_01: So the idea that there was an absolute pure sense and then they eventually decayed
SPEAKER_01: into these other things is kind of I,
SPEAKER_03: at present,
SPEAKER_00: do not have an issue investigating these things.
SPEAKER_00: If there gets to be a point where something comes up and I am uncomfortable, I
SPEAKER_00: will voice it at that time, as I imagine most of us would.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, I just thought it was important for us to talk about it before people were
SPEAKER_02: like, this is not what I signed up for.
SPEAKER_02: I definitely imagine my character is, you know, he's a little bit of a grease
SPEAKER_02: monkey, sort of like mechanic-y sort of guy.
SPEAKER_02: But I imagine him as someone with intense loyalty.
SPEAKER_02: Like, you know, he was in the Navy and he really loves the
SPEAKER_02: empire that he's a part of, even though he's a tiny cog.
SPEAKER_02: And so I imagine this would...
SPEAKER_02: You know, feel like someone's destroying the bedrock of the Foundation.
SPEAKER_02: And so, Like, if people were like, okay, I thought that it would be kind of
SPEAKER_02: like, you know, as time goes on and he, you know, and, you know, more people,
SPEAKER_02: you know, he sees, you know, there's more camaraderie because we, I think that part
SPEAKER_02: of the cool thing about us having a monkey and a robot is that, like, you
SPEAKER_02: know, he gets to see the humanity in everyone else as opposed to being like, oh,
SPEAKER_02: you know, robots and monkeys and dolphins are cool.
SPEAKER_02: Like, You know, where, like, I think a racist would be, like, with, like, an
SPEAKER_02: asterisk, like, this one is cool or that one is fine.
SPEAKER_02: And I think that over time, like, the concept of being, like, oh, perhaps the
SPEAKER_02: bedrock of their foundation was, oh, I was a racist and this is a problem.
SPEAKER_02: Kind of, like, heat of the night sort of thing.
SPEAKER_02: But I can imagine that that's, like,
SPEAKER_02: not thoroughly thrilling for people. So I just didn't want to, like, go down that
SPEAKER_02: road where, like,
SPEAKER_02: nobody...
SPEAKER_01: So, let's get a quick breakdown of what's in the document for research.
SPEAKER_01: Part one is he realizes people are being genetically changed and are being either
SPEAKER_01: blackmailed or preparatory blackmailed by some particular force.
SPEAKER_01: When he investigated this particular force and who could have done this, he
SPEAKER_01: basically learned that social solidarity had found a way to create psychic clones
SPEAKER_01: The psychic clone program has basically branched off and to basically make sure that
SPEAKER_01: they're not eliminated and they have political power and all this other kind of
SPEAKER_01: classic psychore stuff have been basically
SPEAKER_01: infecting the genetic codes of key political figures to make sure that they can
SPEAKER_01: not
SPEAKER_03: challenge them in the future.
SPEAKER_00: Does he have an idea of who the people who are changing it—he knows what they
SPEAKER_00: can do. Does he know who they are?
SPEAKER_01: So he
SPEAKER_01: feels that there is some subset of social solidarity that is running these programs.
SPEAKER_00: But he doesn't know—I guess that's what I'm saying.
SPEAKER_00: He doesn't like Joe in accounting.
SPEAKER_01: Let me break two more pieces just to kind of expand it.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: He has that child data that he was telling in the conversation where he took it
SPEAKER_01: from the infant and then he took it a few years later.
SPEAKER_01: That is in his house.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So if you guys need physical proof, there's a physical proof that you guys can try
SPEAKER_01: to get.
SPEAKER_01: He feels that
SPEAKER_01: he asked for a private meeting with a head of Social Solidarity to investigate
SPEAKER_01: These claims
SPEAKER_01: and that head of
SPEAKER_03: social solidarity is on Providence.
SPEAKER_03: Interesting. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: That he sent someone ahead to do
SPEAKER_01: or to give the information or to, hey, can you answer to these things?
SPEAKER_01: Because remember,
SPEAKER_01: about now is when he should have been
SPEAKER_03: presenting to
SPEAKER_03: the Senate.
SPEAKER_03: Right.
SPEAKER_03: So.
SPEAKER_01: If he would have gone there and he didn't come home,
SPEAKER_01: he couldn't have presented.
SPEAKER_01: So it was his attempt to kind of do a pincer attack on, I'm going to,
SPEAKER_01: he can get a message from Providence because it's all in the same system in a
SPEAKER_01: matter of five to ten minutes.
SPEAKER_01: And they could have basically said, oh, X, Y, and Z is their response to your
SPEAKER_01: arguments. Like when the news report puts out a defamatory thing about someone, you
SPEAKER_01: know, we called for,
SPEAKER_01: A response to our opinion, and then they said nothing.
SPEAKER_01: He basically had someone.
SPEAKER_00: No comment at this time, or no comment at the time of reporting.
SPEAKER_01: Right. He sent someone to Providence to basically ask the head of Social Solidarity,
SPEAKER_01: what's your opinion on this?
SPEAKER_03: But then he died.
SPEAKER_03: Then he died. My opinion is, is you know too
SPEAKER_02: much and you should die.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: It does give some evidence, though, that also the
SPEAKER_01: people who would have tried to stop this information would have been psychers.
SPEAKER_01: And thus, you guys feel a little bit safer.
SPEAKER_01: Maybe you guys were mind-manipulated in the act of the shooting.
SPEAKER_01: Maybe they did teleport bullets.
SPEAKER_01: Maybe you just now are like, okay, well, if he was trying to stop a Psyker
SPEAKER_01: takeover of Social Solidarity or Jordanian politics,
SPEAKER_01: Psykers being involved are pretty high.
SPEAKER_00: Right.
SPEAKER_00: Which I guess, like,
SPEAKER_00: Solves how we were framed, which, you know, at least is a measure of comfort.
SPEAKER_03: Right.
SPEAKER_03: Any questions about the paperwork or what it might reflect before we
SPEAKER_03: move on?
SPEAKER_00: And there's no clue to the identity of the guy that he gave the flight to?
SPEAKER_00: Like, the flight information isn't like current information where it lists a
SPEAKER_00: person's name?
SPEAKER_01: No, but someone could attempt to
SPEAKER_01: fast-talk or hack or find some type of data.
SPEAKER_01: Like, you have the flight number, and you have the seat number.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: You could try to be like...
SPEAKER_03: Who took that seat.
SPEAKER_03: You could try to
SPEAKER_01: do it in your normal Solstack way of someone knows.
SPEAKER_01: Someone.
SPEAKER_03: But
SPEAKER_03: you have the seat, you have the flight number, and you know the seat was taken.
SPEAKER_00: I'm just contemplating, do I want to try to hack the space airline to get a
SPEAKER_00: manifest?
SPEAKER_02: Do you
SPEAKER_02: have contacts, right? Maybe one of your contacts could like
SPEAKER_02: Hit up the company and get the information without hacking.
SPEAKER_00: A lot of my contacts are kind of shady people, like smugglers and stuff like that.
SPEAKER_00: Or there's one that's actually a guru, so I don't...
SPEAKER_01: It is transport.
SPEAKER_01: It's what? I'm sorry?
SPEAKER_01: It was a transport-like flight. Like, maybe smugglers would know about transports.
SPEAKER_00: Well, okay. Well, let me look at my contacts list then.
SPEAKER_01: Exactly two contacts, one's a criminal, and one just says someone who works at the
SPEAKER_01: spaceport.
SPEAKER_01: Someone who works at the spaceport, you could be like,
SPEAKER_03: that's the guy who was there loading that flight.
SPEAKER_03: All right, hold on. This guy might work.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, this guy will work.
SPEAKER_03: Hold on.
SPEAKER_03: Can I copy this? Yeah, okay.
SPEAKER_01: Carefully compartmentalize one call set personnel under provides access restricted
SPEAKER_01: travel grants. Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, OK, travel clearance.
SPEAKER_00: All right, so I'd like to reach out to Mark Duncan.
SPEAKER_00: OK,
SPEAKER_01: you can reach out to Mark Duncan
SPEAKER_01: and you give the data and he returns.
SPEAKER_01: First, he says with
SPEAKER_01: What do you need it for?
SPEAKER_00: Well, does he say anything about, like, hey, you're wanted for murder?
SPEAKER_01: I
SPEAKER_01: imagine you're sending the message to him under one of your multiple cover
SPEAKER_01: identities of being a Substack agent.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. So he doesn't actually know me as
SPEAKER_01: M.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: He knows you as
SPEAKER_00: M. Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: We were just talking about that show the other day.
SPEAKER_00: I'm going to say something a little vague. It has the potential to blow a case
SPEAKER_00: wide open.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, but it could get me in trouble. It'll be with you in ten minutes.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, well, I owe you big time then.
SPEAKER_03: I have a question.
SPEAKER_03: Sorry, after you're finished.
SPEAKER_00: I think I'm done. It's going to be ten minutes.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. You get a record and you get a photo of a
SPEAKER_01: woman in a black kind of uniform.
SPEAKER_01: Her ID is encrypted and it is that she is actually
SPEAKER_01: a Solstack agent.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, okay. Camille Dufour.
SPEAKER_00: I have someone in my office named Renee Dufour.
SPEAKER_03: And she's a major.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: And I don't know that name at all, right?
SPEAKER_01: I'll let you do an admin or an associate to see if you know her.
SPEAKER_00: Heck yeah.
SPEAKER_00: An admin or a what, I'm sorry?
SPEAKER_01: Advocate.
SPEAKER_03: Local gadget.
SPEAKER_03: Laurel.
SPEAKER_01: By the way, you stole the boon from the previous leadership on this.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, sweet.
SPEAKER_03: Isn't it great to have great leaders?
SPEAKER_00: It does.
SPEAKER_02: The previous Traveler campaign was blessed to have a
SPEAKER_03: good leader, too.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, I don't know anything.
SPEAKER_03: That was actually a little dig at Steimach and
SPEAKER_02: Kolb, but they were silent.
SPEAKER_00: I don't know what the dig was, yeah, we were great leaders, and you were a
SPEAKER_00: good leader, so, you know, no digs. That's so sweet.
SPEAKER_00: I mean, you weren't a great leader, but you were a good leader.
SPEAKER_03: Thanks.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, you led us right to the best swarm of places on planet.
SPEAKER_01: Delicious.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so yeah, it basically was a Solstack person who was working for Mercer that's
SPEAKER_01: the only person he could trust and be secretive enough with this machine.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: All right.
SPEAKER_03: Who's next?
SPEAKER_03: Me, please. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: All
SPEAKER_00: right.
SPEAKER_00: So I have – I only have one contact, right?
SPEAKER_00: My guerrilla contact, but I have three allies, and allies are better than contacts.
SPEAKER_00: One of my allies is an influential Soleimani party member, and another one of them
SPEAKER_00: is a crusading journalist.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: What would you like to do? I reveal this information
SPEAKER_00: to the party.
SPEAKER_00: What do we think about
SPEAKER_00: funneling some of this
SPEAKER_00: to either of those?
SPEAKER_02: When you said party, I thought you meant the Soleimani party, and then I realized
SPEAKER_02: you mean the players.
SPEAKER_00: No, I mean the
SPEAKER_02: Soleimani party.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, you do mean you're revealing the information to the party.
SPEAKER_00: I misunderstood. Yeah, I'm revealing the information to the players, that I have an
SPEAKER_00: ally that's influential in the Soleimani party, as well as a crusading journalist,
SPEAKER_00: Roman Juma.
SPEAKER_02: I'm fine with information.
SPEAKER_02: I think these details, like that this particular guy has it and where it's located,
SPEAKER_02: that's something we don't want to share. But I think the vague details...
SPEAKER_02: The more people who have it, the less reason to kill us.
SPEAKER_02: I think that's what I think.
SPEAKER_00: I feel like that will cause chaos.
SPEAKER_02: Maybe, but every person you share it with, keep in mind,
SPEAKER_03: may be killed.
SPEAKER_03: That's all.
SPEAKER_03: I would like to bring up an angle, too.
SPEAKER_03: Until you guys have proof,
SPEAKER_03: it's like saying, hey, you know, there are extraterrestrials.
SPEAKER_03: But we know where the proof is to get the proof.
SPEAKER_01: Do you know where Mercer said the proof is?
SPEAKER_00: We know where Mercer said the proof is.
SPEAKER_02: He's like, we're not going to be there anymore.
SPEAKER_02: He's like, I removed it before the Chronicle began already.
SPEAKER_01: In tilting your grubby hands, you should understand that there is no proof.
SPEAKER_00: So here's my thought.
SPEAKER_00: Instead of risking ourselves to go and get this proof, if I feed this information to
SPEAKER_00: Roman Juma, the crusading journalist, as where – like to go and get the – where
SPEAKER_00: he can go and get that proof from the senator's quarters
SPEAKER_00: and let him be the
SPEAKER_03: fucking –
SPEAKER_03: do with the B&E.
SPEAKER_01: Is everyone cool with the Crusading Journalist doing the act of going into Mercers?
SPEAKER_00: I think that's a good way to get them killed because they already had Mercer killed.
SPEAKER_02: I don't mind. I just want you to know that, one, there's a decent chance they're
SPEAKER_02: going to get killed.
SPEAKER_02: My general out-of-character understanding is that
SPEAKER_02: storytellers don't love that sort of stuff being outsourced.
SPEAKER_02: And finally, what if this person is suborned or psyched?
SPEAKER_02: I will say, Colt, by the way, if the person attempts to acquire them, they will
SPEAKER_02: be just as successful as the players are getting the objects.
SPEAKER_03: I think it's a bad idea. I
SPEAKER_00: think it's more a great person to have if we need to apply pressure.
SPEAKER_00: We go, we get the evidence, we get enough pieces to clear our name, and then
SPEAKER_00: we have leverage of, oh, we have a contact in the press that can get this
SPEAKER_00: out, but you should just clear our names and then we won't represent this proof out
SPEAKER_00: there.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, I prefer it.
SPEAKER_01: What about a dead man switch?
SPEAKER_01: What about if you put all the data that if you don't respond to it every
SPEAKER_01: 24 hours, it goes to the journalist?
SPEAKER_01: I dig that. I'm with that.
SPEAKER_00: I might suggest 48 instead of 24 in case we get sent on a mission or
SPEAKER_00: if we have to go off-world.
SPEAKER_01: Well, depending on what he sends back, the next one needs to be 48 or 24
SPEAKER_01: hours.
SPEAKER_03: Mm-hmm.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, so we are going to go send the guy to do it as opposed to
SPEAKER_00: us doing it.
SPEAKER_01: No, no, no.
SPEAKER_01: Colm has the dead man switch. Every day he has to respond.
SPEAKER_01: If he responds with A, he has to respond again in 24 hours.
SPEAKER_01: If he responds with B, he has to respond every 48 hours.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, okay, okay.
SPEAKER_00: And if there's a duress code, it goes out immediately.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Got it.
SPEAKER_03: I like that idea.
SPEAKER_00: Do you like that idea, Colt, because it's your guy?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, I like that idea. That's kind of like what I really, like, yeah, yes.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: I want to be useful, and this is what I have to be useful with, so
SPEAKER_00: yes.
SPEAKER_01: I will also say, by using both of them, you can guarantee
SPEAKER_01: that her data
SPEAKER_03: won't be blocked by the government.
SPEAKER_03: Hell yeah. Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Because you have one government person and you have one journalist person, you can
SPEAKER_01: wonder team, wonder twins combined.
SPEAKER_01: Their powers combined. To try to stop that data.
SPEAKER_03: I'm here for it.
SPEAKER_01: Thank you.
SPEAKER_01: I even think just to show that it's going to happen easier is you're actually going
SPEAKER_01: to have it transmitted off of the planet Carson where there's less like authority.
SPEAKER_01: And it's going to be transmitted to the entire Jardinian sector.
SPEAKER_01: So even though Jardinian may have a lockdown on media, it's going to hit one planet
SPEAKER_01: after a planet after a planet, and then it's going to hit the ships, and then
SPEAKER_01: it's eventually going to keep reinfecting the data.
SPEAKER_00: The blockchain of evil.
SPEAKER_00: Yep.
SPEAKER_00: No, a blockchain of good. Yeah, I was going to say, maybe not evil of information.
SPEAKER_00: Blockchain fighting evil.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So,
SPEAKER_01: who is going to...
SPEAKER_01: Now the players are going to go to the house.
SPEAKER_01: Who wants to go
SPEAKER_03: to the house?
SPEAKER_03: I'm happy to be a backup. I've been muted.
SPEAKER_03: Sorry.
SPEAKER_02: Now that we have a smaller party, are we still breaking up the party?
SPEAKER_02: Well, I think that...
SPEAKER_00: I don't know, man. The whole lot of us going to one guy's house just
SPEAKER_00: seems like...
SPEAKER_00: I'm overly cautious all the time, so... Okay, then I'll stay back.
SPEAKER_00: No problem.
SPEAKER_00: Well, if you want to go, that's different than all of us going.
SPEAKER_02: No, no, no. I just thought that, like, with nine people, it was, like, a lot.
SPEAKER_02: But at seven, I was like, maybe we should just all stay together.
SPEAKER_02: But I don't think that my character is...
SPEAKER_02: I'm not especially Marshall.
SPEAKER_02: I'm not a computer hacker.
SPEAKER_02: I think Investigate is probably going to be the most relevant skill that I have,
SPEAKER_02: which is decent. But besides, I don't know if we have a lot of investigators, but
SPEAKER_02: besides that, I don't think I'm super useful.
SPEAKER_02: So I'm fine staying back.
SPEAKER_00: Would it take a lot of time to upload life support and power?
SPEAKER_00: I don't think any of us have that.
SPEAKER_03: Upload what to what?
SPEAKER_03: To the pad.
SPEAKER_03: Or are you guys taking it?
SPEAKER_01: So, by the way, the pad is not going to act as a skill.
SPEAKER_01: We have multiple pads.
SPEAKER_01: Right.
SPEAKER_01: It's not going to act as a skill. It's when you guys have literally weeks of
SPEAKER_01: doing nothing, you can read that to try to learn the skill.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, that's what I'm saying. Like, that's why I want to upload it.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah. Everyone has two skills that they're looking for on their phones.
SPEAKER_00: Cool. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, I'd probably stay back then, because, yeah, not to declutter.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Presumably you guys would want Annette, the powerhouse gunfighter of the group.
SPEAKER_01: Yes.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, so she is required on most away missions.
SPEAKER_02: Wait, who's protecting me while she's over there?
SPEAKER_00: So she is away mission priority numero uno.
SPEAKER_01: Annette, are you back from the bathroom and interested in going?
SPEAKER_00: Oh, yeah, yeah, sorry, I've just been quiet, yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_02: Does anyone else have Investigate? Because if there's no Investigate, I should go,
SPEAKER_02: otherwise then I'm going to stay.
SPEAKER_00: I technically have Investigate at zero.
SPEAKER_00: But, yeah, that's not particularly helpful.
SPEAKER_00: I do not have Investigate.
SPEAKER_02: If you'd like, I'll come because I added a two, not including my attributes.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So,
SPEAKER_01: every player that is coming,
SPEAKER_01: I'm just going to make a blank map where I'm going to put them on.
SPEAKER_03: We've got to go to scenes.
SPEAKER_03: Great scene.
SPEAKER_03: Great.
SPEAKER_00: I'm going to step away real quick and fill up my water bottle.
SPEAKER_03: I'll be right back.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: And
SPEAKER_03: we are going to activate blank.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So, before I get
SPEAKER_01: any aspect of confusion, I just want to, again, go down the list of who is
SPEAKER_01: going and who is not. Okay. Annette is going.
SPEAKER_01: Kolb, are you going?
SPEAKER_01: Yes.
SPEAKER_01: Peter, you are not going, because you're not here.
SPEAKER_01: Josh, are you going?
SPEAKER_03: Yes.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Laura?
SPEAKER_00: No.
SPEAKER_01: Alan, no.
SPEAKER_01: Right.
SPEAKER_01: And Steinbach, yes.
SPEAKER_01: Daniel, are you?
SPEAKER_00: No.
SPEAKER_00: I know.
SPEAKER_01: Study investigation on one of these books
SPEAKER_01: that we've been downloading.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So...
SPEAKER_01: The four players that go in, as they are going to this particular high-rise, he has
SPEAKER_01: basically
SPEAKER_01: a penthouse suite in one of the towers.
SPEAKER_01: You guys go over and you use this personal code to get in.
SPEAKER_01: You're going up the elevator, and as the elevator opens entirely on his floor,
SPEAKER_01: you,
SPEAKER_01: without any role,
SPEAKER_03: hear
SPEAKER_03: People stop moving.
SPEAKER_03: That's bad.
SPEAKER_03: I become weapons ready.
SPEAKER_03: Does anyone have a...
SPEAKER_02: Wait, so we're currently in the hallway, and we hear there was moving inside the
SPEAKER_02: place?
SPEAKER_01: No, so this is one of those penthouses where the elevator opens
SPEAKER_02: inside the apartment.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, I see. So it goes ding, and it opens up, and all of a sudden
SPEAKER_02: you hear rummaging, and all of a sudden it goes silent, and we're like, fuck.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah.
SPEAKER_03: Hmm, that's not...
SPEAKER_03: I'm like, guys, um...
SPEAKER_01: If anyone wants to roll a Military Tactics at zero, I'd be happy to get it.
SPEAKER_01: I know no one has that one.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: You do it.
SPEAKER_03: One of the plans might be is to have Soshi
SPEAKER_03: fight from the ceiling.
SPEAKER_03: Because if they aim at her, With all of her incredible armor, you guys are not
SPEAKER_03: going to get hit in the crossfire.
SPEAKER_03: Because you guys are much softer than she is.
SPEAKER_03: That is offensive and accurate.
SPEAKER_03: And she can walk on walls.
SPEAKER_02: Yep. If you're going to move forward and go at them, do you want to
SPEAKER_02: go at the ceiling?
SPEAKER_02: That's less in our direction.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, and then I give a quiet nod and then start to gecko spider up the
SPEAKER_00: outside of the elevator shaft.
SPEAKER_00: I want to protest against the idea of a gecko spider.
SPEAKER_00: I don't like that.
SPEAKER_00: Robot gecko spider is a thing now.
SPEAKER_01: Let me see if I can do this on a better way.
SPEAKER_01: Is that you throwing up?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah. No, it was me making sounds. Just like, oh, God!
SPEAKER_03: What are you going to do?
SPEAKER_02: So, I get... Can I do, like, an investigative role?
SPEAKER_01: One second.
SPEAKER_01: I'm still setting up from her actually walking out.
SPEAKER_01: No one else did.
SPEAKER_01: No worries.
SPEAKER_01: Sorry.
SPEAKER_03: That's okay.
SPEAKER_01: I just...
SPEAKER_03: Vandri is not the quickest to do a...
SPEAKER_03: We don't want death. We want not death.
SPEAKER_02: Listen, we're okay not doing combat. I don't know that there needs to be combat.
SPEAKER_02: There needs to be combat.
SPEAKER_00: When Sochi goes and prepares to enter, I will follow right behind.
SPEAKER_00: I
SPEAKER_00: crouch, combat stance,
SPEAKER_00: clear the room.
SPEAKER_03: I'm probably the second best armored.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: So, as though she comes out,
SPEAKER_01: a home guard police shoots past her
SPEAKER_01: into the elevator.
SPEAKER_01: They look like home guard police.
SPEAKER_01: And
SPEAKER_01: why is there... Oh, because I pulled off all their guns when you guys stole them.
SPEAKER_03: Hey,
SPEAKER_03: hey, hey, hey.
SPEAKER_03: Let's see if I can do it the easier way.
SPEAKER_01: Does Peter have one of these? Yes, he does.
SPEAKER_01: We're just going to duplicate Peter.
SPEAKER_01: Actually, now I've got to do it the other way.
SPEAKER_03: Items, Navel.
SPEAKER_03: Well, that's
SPEAKER_03: you.
SPEAKER_03: Close.
SPEAKER_03: You have one.
SPEAKER_03: Okay, they all have their
SPEAKER_01: guns now. Okay, so now close that, go back to combat, go back to the
SPEAKER_01: first guy, and he is going
SPEAKER_01: attack Victor.
SPEAKER_01: It is going to be with the Bane because you have the cover of the elevator.
SPEAKER_03: That is still a fairly
SPEAKER_03: strong hit.
SPEAKER_03: Steinbach, you should have the ability now to spread your damage.
SPEAKER_03: I'm sorry, is it on me?
SPEAKER_03: Nope, I said Steinbeck, you have the ability
SPEAKER_01: to spread your damage, and I've never heard a statement from Steinbeck.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, apologies, I had just gotten back to my...
SPEAKER_00: My wife also arrived home while I was getting my water bottle, so...
SPEAKER_00: Apologies. Alright, so, spreading damage, we are being attacked, then, I take it?
SPEAKER_01: Yes, you just took 21 damage.
SPEAKER_03: Oof!
SPEAKER_00: Um...
SPEAKER_00: Let's see. If
SPEAKER_00: I...
SPEAKER_00: It has to go to Endurance first, and then I can spread it over Strength and
SPEAKER_00: Dex?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: So, dump your entire Endurance, it's 9.
SPEAKER_01: And then you can dump it into...
SPEAKER_01: Dex would then take you to 18.
SPEAKER_01: It's 12 points.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, 12 points, I'm going to have to do 6 and 6, so that I don't
SPEAKER_00: die.
SPEAKER_00: No, you only die when you lose all 3. Oh, okay.
SPEAKER_00: You're not going to
SPEAKER_01: lose all 3. I do think...
SPEAKER_00: I'll still split between Strength and Dex.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah. So, Victor takes a shotgun blast in the chest.
SPEAKER_02: Are we all still inside the elevator? Yeah.
SPEAKER_03: He rolled that with a Bane, by the way.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah. So, the only one who's out of the elevator is Soshi.
SPEAKER_03: Oh.
SPEAKER_02: And
SPEAKER_02: what did he call it? Said he was going to leave.
SPEAKER_02: Culp said he was going to, like, spread out, right?
SPEAKER_02: Or no?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, I said I was following Soshi.
SPEAKER_00: I'm crouched low.
SPEAKER_00: So she went high, I've gone low.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so the next personal combat character is Victor.
SPEAKER_01: Victor, do you have any medical capability?
SPEAKER_01: Do you patch yourself up, or are you
SPEAKER_00: going to have... I do have a couple points in Medic.
SPEAKER_00: I apologize, I did think that in...
SPEAKER_00: When you lost Endurance, I thought you fell unconscious.
SPEAKER_01: Is that not true? It's true because you lost it all in one turn.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah.
SPEAKER_03: You're right. You're out cold. Sorry.
SPEAKER_03: And okay. So we're on the second home guard police.
SPEAKER_03: He's got a suit.
SPEAKER_03: So she's out. So there's no.
SPEAKER_03: That is
SPEAKER_03: 15, but the armor is going to take most of that off.
SPEAKER_03: Okay, you should have a damage chart
SPEAKER_03: for you now.
SPEAKER_03: I see it.
SPEAKER_03: Apply damage.
SPEAKER_01: Yep.
SPEAKER_01: And you pick how you want to do it.
SPEAKER_01: Even if you're at no Endurance, I don't think you go down.
SPEAKER_01: I think as a robot, you go down when you are out of the stats.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, 11 to apply 20 Endurance, so I will just apply.
SPEAKER_00: All to my Endurance, I'm still at nine Endurance.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, and now we're back in
SPEAKER_01: combat, and we're on Dan. What would you like to do, Dan?
SPEAKER_03: I
SPEAKER_03: think I have
SPEAKER_02: some medic.
SPEAKER_03: I think I'm gonna try and patch up the guy who looks like he's bleeding to
SPEAKER_03: death.
SPEAKER_03: Okay. Steinbach, you have four endurance.
SPEAKER_03: Sweet.
SPEAKER_03: Victor gives a...
SPEAKER_00: ...breath
SPEAKER_00: as he wakes back up.
SPEAKER_02: Don't be so dramatic, Victor.
SPEAKER_01: He's got shot in the chest.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: He had a gushing chest wound.
SPEAKER_01: You, like, filled it with foam. He takes the breath, like, don't be dramatic.
SPEAKER_02: That wasn't what I said in character. I thought it was funny for players.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, either way, yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so Victor is no longer down.
SPEAKER_02: You're like, Dan, you saved my life, but you're a real asshole, Dan.
SPEAKER_01: Tass, you're up for the roll.
SPEAKER_03: It's just a flesh wound.
SPEAKER_03: I'm attacking.
SPEAKER_01: Are you going to attack the one that... Are you going to attack the one that
SPEAKER_01: shot...
SPEAKER_01: Steinbach's character, you can attack one that hasn't acted yet.
SPEAKER_01: I'm gonna attack the one that hasn't acted yet.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: Roll that mean footage.
SPEAKER_03: Big brain.
SPEAKER_03: Wow.
SPEAKER_03: And
SPEAKER_03: it's a mess. I'll say he ducks, though.
SPEAKER_03: He ducks.
SPEAKER_02: I liked your moxie, though. It was strategically a good idea.
SPEAKER_00: It's doing something wrong, because it has me taking a minus two, and it should be
SPEAKER_00: a plus two.
SPEAKER_01: Let's take a second to look at your weapon.
SPEAKER_03: So I'm going to open up your laser pistol.
SPEAKER_00: It says... It does say plus negative two.
SPEAKER_00: Because it says skill none, and I have laser at two.
SPEAKER_03: Um...
SPEAKER_03: Why does that say scale that?
SPEAKER_03: Let's
SPEAKER_03: take a second to see if you just have an old laser piston before I fix
SPEAKER_03: them.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: Okay,
SPEAKER_03: roll again.
SPEAKER_03: The skill went none again.
SPEAKER_01: The skill went none again, even when I pulled it on your sheet.
SPEAKER_01: If I go to your sheet and I add this other pistol,
SPEAKER_01: And I go edit,
SPEAKER_03: it still says skill none.
SPEAKER_03: Is it that your skill...
SPEAKER_00: He's got energy at one. Energy at one, and slug at two.
SPEAKER_00: Regardless, I'm skilled. It should not be skill none.
SPEAKER_00: Right.
SPEAKER_01: It has to be something with the way that you're...
SPEAKER_01: Your skill was written.
SPEAKER_01: For now, what I want you to do, let me look at how it showed your
SPEAKER_01: role.
SPEAKER_03: The last one said two.
SPEAKER_01: When I looked at the role, it's a skill DM2.
SPEAKER_00: The DM, it should be a total of two.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah,
SPEAKER_01: so the second one did role correct.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: I wish I could see it. Like, see what dice it rolled to verify that it's
SPEAKER_00: doing correctly.
SPEAKER_01: It says you rolled a five.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, but like, what were the two dice that were rolled?
SPEAKER_03: You know what I mean?
SPEAKER_03: I want to see if I can try something here. If I go...
SPEAKER_03: Attack DM2.
SPEAKER_03: And...
SPEAKER_03: I...
SPEAKER_03: Click on that one again, and I click on Edit, Attack CM2, and I'm going to
SPEAKER_03: click Attack.
SPEAKER_03: And it says...
SPEAKER_03: Oh, why does that say negative 2?
SPEAKER_03: Okay, I clicked on 2.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so that now is negative 2 plus 2.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so that is correct.
SPEAKER_01: It's negative two, plus twos, and plus two.
SPEAKER_01: You have two at the skill, right?
SPEAKER_01: Or you have one at the skill?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, it gives two.
SPEAKER_00: You should have a plus one from his dex and plus one from his energy.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so that's rolling at least that one is right.
SPEAKER_01: We'll just make sure that one's correct.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Because the thing is, I have to recode the character sheets, which I can't do while
SPEAKER_01: we're doing this. Yeah, sorry to have found a bug.
SPEAKER_01: No worries, I'm happy we found it and we'll just work on it during the week.
SPEAKER_01: But okay, so you are shooting one that has not acted.
SPEAKER_01: So
SPEAKER_01: let's pull him up and let's have him take that damage.
SPEAKER_03: And
SPEAKER_03: that is unconscious.
SPEAKER_03: Nice work, nice work.
SPEAKER_03: Okay, now we're on and out.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: One down, four to go.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Are you going to go straight laser rifle on one of the ones you have enacted?
SPEAKER_00: That's correct.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Do you want to click the attack roll?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah. And I just click the red attack button on laser rifle.
SPEAKER_00: Yep. Correct. Yep.
SPEAKER_00: Bip.
SPEAKER_00: No modifiers.
SPEAKER_03: Single shot. Hit attack.
SPEAKER_03: Bop.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, that's perfect.
SPEAKER_01: That's the way that roll goes.
SPEAKER_01: Roll that beautiful bean damage.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, 22 would be a death. There's no way that Homeguard even with armor can throw
SPEAKER_01: out
SPEAKER_01: 22.
SPEAKER_03: Apply.
SPEAKER_03: Actually, he's only unconscious.
SPEAKER_01: Doubly.
SPEAKER_01: He lost all of his endurance and all of his dex.
SPEAKER_00: All's Endurance
SPEAKER_01: and all his decks. Boom.
SPEAKER_00: He's done enough for me. Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: I will move on to the next part.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, that is bleeding to death.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: This robot
SPEAKER_03: is helping.
SPEAKER_01: That has not acted. He is going to shoot Annette with a shotgun.
SPEAKER_01: She just blows people away. 14. Sweetheart.
SPEAKER_01: There's your pop-up.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, yuck.
SPEAKER_01: And it has to go to Endurance first?
SPEAKER_01: No.
SPEAKER_01: Your first damage total has to go to Endurance.
SPEAKER_01: If you've gotten damage, you can go to anything you want.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: And I honestly think maybe as a robot, it might not even need to go to
SPEAKER_01: Endurance first.
SPEAKER_01: It hit an art ticket, like it hit a PowerPoint, it hit a whatever, it's not
SPEAKER_01: like a human
SPEAKER_03: body, so.
SPEAKER_03: So you take less damage?
SPEAKER_03: I don't know if it works like that, actually.
SPEAKER_01: The thing is, she automatically has a higher natural armor than most people,
SPEAKER_01: and
SPEAKER_01: she has like 40 endurance normally, and she has 11 dex and 9 strength.
SPEAKER_01: She has a lot she can head off.
SPEAKER_01: It still sucks.
SPEAKER_01: It still does major wound damage, so...
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Now we are back on the top of the list.
SPEAKER_01: We are
SPEAKER_01: on another home guard who is now going
SPEAKER_01: attempt to shoot casts
SPEAKER_03: because casts did not go down.
SPEAKER_03: And he is going to attack.
SPEAKER_03: And it's
SPEAKER_03: not actually going to be very much strong because you have the Carface Armor.
SPEAKER_03: So it's only going to be six damage. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: We are now back on
SPEAKER_01: Steinbach, who is now somewhat conscious.
SPEAKER_00: I did something wrong, because...
SPEAKER_00: Yep, I did something wrong.
SPEAKER_03: I accidentally applied 10 damage instead of 6.
SPEAKER_03: Oh.
SPEAKER_03: Can you fix that, or do you need me to do that?
SPEAKER_03: I figured out how to fix it.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: So, being jerked back to life and being told, don't be so dramatic in
SPEAKER_00: the moment that Josh's character is distracted.
SPEAKER_00: I see one of the enemies over his shoulder and it looks like they're sort of
SPEAKER_00: pointing the gun in our direction.
SPEAKER_00: So one hand reaches up cinematically and pulls Josh down to the side a little bit
SPEAKER_00: as the other hand draws my pistol, the Liberator pistol, and I start firing at one
SPEAKER_00: of the other guards that has the shotgun.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: Rule type normal.
SPEAKER_03: Yep, that's a hit.
SPEAKER_03: Hit for nine damage.
SPEAKER_03: Okay, let's
SPEAKER_03: go to the sky.
SPEAKER_03: He is
SPEAKER_01: holding onto
SPEAKER_01: his chest as he is bleeding directly out of his chest.
SPEAKER_01: You basically shot in between his neck and the
SPEAKER_03: flag vest.
SPEAKER_03: Nice.
SPEAKER_03: And it is Dan's turn.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, so, you know, I'm gonna, you know, if I gotta fight, I gotta fight.
SPEAKER_02: So I'm gonna do a gun combat, I guess.
SPEAKER_02: So I guess I have my shotgun thing is what I would have.
SPEAKER_02: So I just roll gun combat slug? Oh no, actually it says I have an attack
SPEAKER_02: pistol. Where's my
SPEAKER_02: equipment?
SPEAKER_01: It says you have an assault pistol right down on your character sheet under the
SPEAKER_01: attacks.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, but I would have the combat shot. Can I switch it by dragging it?
SPEAKER_02: Is that how it works?
SPEAKER_01: No, it doesn't.
SPEAKER_01: Never mind, I'll just
SPEAKER_02: keep the pistol. It's simple.
SPEAKER_01: No, no, it's fine. It doesn't.
SPEAKER_01: So all we do is we click that as you're carrying it, and then we're going
SPEAKER_01: to Box away your assault pistol, you now have that as your attack on the left.
SPEAKER_02: And so now I just hit attack and that's it?
Yep.
SPEAKER_03: I missed with a seven still, wow.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: I will say, though, it makes the
SPEAKER_01: guy duck.
SPEAKER_02: What number did I need to hit with a seven missed?
SPEAKER_02: Probably eight or more, probably, right?
SPEAKER_01: Probably eight or more, yeah. On two does, yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, but I'm not a shooter, guys.
SPEAKER_01: Cass?
SPEAKER_00: I, uh, I'm going to continue firing away.
SPEAKER_00: Uh, is there, like, a take cover, uh, mechanic?
SPEAKER_00: Or shoot from cover?
SPEAKER_00: Uh, there's a take cover mechanic that takes a turn.
SPEAKER_00: Then I'm going to blast- I'm gonna blast him.
SPEAKER_00: I keep on blasting.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, I'm gonna do the roll just so we- so we don't have to worry about
SPEAKER_01: the mechanic.
SPEAKER_01: Um...
SPEAKER_01: I'm going to do the attack, and you hit
SPEAKER_03: 14, that's going to take another one out.
SPEAKER_03: Okay,
SPEAKER_03: there is
SPEAKER_03: one that is still up, and it's Saatchi's turn.
SPEAKER_03: You are muted, by the way, Annette.
SPEAKER_03: Sorry, I was solving a logistical home issue.
SPEAKER_00: We've got first day of school tomorrow.
SPEAKER_00: Ooh!
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: It goes well.
SPEAKER_00: Is it my action? Is that what we're up with?
SPEAKER_01: Yep, it's your action. Only one last target left.
SPEAKER_00: Well, then that last target is who I'm
SPEAKER_03: going to shoot.
SPEAKER_03: Okay. Laser rifle.
SPEAKER_03: Pew, pew. Okay.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, that guy's dead. 22.
SPEAKER_03: Yep. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: They're all dead or bleeding to death.
SPEAKER_00: As soon as they're all down, I
SPEAKER_00: quickly disconnect from the ceiling and
SPEAKER_00: land on the ground and then drop to one knee because I'm damaged.
SPEAKER_00: I say we've got to move fast. They get a backup on the way.
SPEAKER_00: I secure the home guard, take away their comms.
SPEAKER_00: Even if they're dead, I handcuff them with their own cups.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. As you're this close, can you give me an investigate?
SPEAKER_01: Me or him?
SPEAKER_03: Kolb is the one who's touching them.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah,
SPEAKER_01: you notice nothing.
SPEAKER_01: You pack them up, you get all that going.
SPEAKER_01: Now every other player can roll a recon to pick up the key data.
SPEAKER_03: Wow, Steinbach.
SPEAKER_01: They're
SPEAKER_01: like, a bullet to the chest to make sure you have keen awareness.
SPEAKER_02: He's hyper-aware of all the pain and everything else going around.
SPEAKER_01: Wow. And Annette also got a five. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So you notice that there is a secret door behind his television
SPEAKER_01: screen.
SPEAKER_01: You guys open it up and you see that he had...
SPEAKER_01: Five different actual example samples of people who had one aspect of the genetic
SPEAKER_01: code and then how it changed.
SPEAKER_01: He also has a bit of a research piece of how he thinks the changes are
SPEAKER_01: occurring genetically.
SPEAKER_01: And he has a few photos of people who he thinks are part of
SPEAKER_01: this
SPEAKER_01: social solidarity opposition group.
SPEAKER_01: He also has a communicator hidden there and
SPEAKER_01: he has a
SPEAKER_01: laser pistol which is very similar to Cass's.
SPEAKER_03: I would also say he has probably $200,000 in credits in there.
SPEAKER_03: Hell yeah.
SPEAKER_00: I think we take everything from the vault.
SPEAKER_00: If
SPEAKER_00: the samples have to be cryogenically frozen, we might have an issue there.
SPEAKER_01: It's almost like
SPEAKER_01: blood
SPEAKER_03: drops on slides.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: And then there's basically a readout next to it of what the results are.
SPEAKER_02: So then no investigate skill is needed for this, is what you're saying?
SPEAKER_02: No, this was recon because
SPEAKER_01: it was all...
SPEAKER_01: It's kind of a huge place. He has a palatial kind of...
SPEAKER_01: That's ironic.
SPEAKER_02: So there was no reason for me to come anyway, and I almost died.
SPEAKER_00: Well, you fixed up Victor.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, and I would love you to fix me up too.
SPEAKER_00: I'll do a minute.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, yeah, you want to do a first date on Cass?
SPEAKER_00: I believe in you. You're going to be so good at this.
SPEAKER_00: You're the best doctor ever.
SPEAKER_02: I just want to note that I specifically made this character to not be the Baron,
SPEAKER_02: and he is not nearly as good of a medic.
SPEAKER_02: Sorry, you're very inspired. I was supposed to do a boon, sorry, but it's still plus
SPEAKER_02: two.
SPEAKER_01: A five is as bad as—oh, so plus two.
SPEAKER_01: I'll let you roll again with the boon.
SPEAKER_00: I feel bad now I stayed back.
SPEAKER_00: I thought we were trying to keep numbers low.
SPEAKER_01: There you go, six.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Actually, I think he's fully healed. Yeah, that fixes me.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, that first aid sealed him up.
SPEAKER_02: Can I do my robotics on the robot?
SPEAKER_01: Yep, you can.
SPEAKER_01: And your robotics is a science, right?
SPEAKER_02: Yes, we fixed it, I think.
SPEAKER_02: Can I boon that one also, since you got a bunch of successes, I think?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, you got two. You can find out.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so that's six.
SPEAKER_01: So Annette instantly heals six.
SPEAKER_01: Let's take it that there's no dex problem right now and her endurance is...
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: You basically do that by like putting wires where they belong and like quickly
SPEAKER_01: welding stuff shut.
SPEAKER_01: Can I medic myself?
SPEAKER_01: No.
SPEAKER_01: Since this is the first time people have been heavily damaged, let's kind of go over
SPEAKER_01: again how the healing scenario works.
SPEAKER_01: First aid has to occur
SPEAKER_01: within rounds of the damage.
SPEAKER_01: If you guys wait a scene or two, you can't first aid at all.
SPEAKER_01: After that, only endurance can naturally be healed with time.
SPEAKER_03: The other stats can only be healed with surgery.
SPEAKER_03: Right.
SPEAKER_01: So, you cannot add any other first aids. You cannot do any other medics.
SPEAKER_01: You have to be on a medical bed undergoing surgery of them pulling pellets out of
SPEAKER_01: your chest.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, guys, I'm not in good shape here.
SPEAKER_03: I... Mr.
SPEAKER_03: Bless you. We grab and go.
SPEAKER_00: I need shawarma.
SPEAKER_00: Should we make it look like the place got tossed, like there were criminals hunting
SPEAKER_00: for other things and they just found the vault?
SPEAKER_01: The place is pretty tossed, by the way.
SPEAKER_02: Are you worried about the people having seen our faces?
SPEAKER_01: They're all dead. I thought they were all dead.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, I thought they were bleeding out, so good luck.
SPEAKER_01: They're not getting medical attention. No one's first dating them.
SPEAKER_01: They're going to be dead in four turns.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, I just didn't know if, like, when the police show up and they go into
SPEAKER_02: an ambulance, they're like, it was the criminals of state.
SPEAKER_03: It was Dan.
SPEAKER_03: Jacuzze.
SPEAKER_03: Exactly. I don't want to be jacuzzed.
SPEAKER_03: So,
SPEAKER_03: yeah, let's grab this stuff and we'll get out of here, you know?
SPEAKER_03: Sounds good.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Victor, though, is also not bleeding to death because he was first-aided.
SPEAKER_01: Yes. If you're not first-aided, you do keep losing endurance and stats until you
SPEAKER_01: die.
SPEAKER_00: I'm still at 17 points of damage, effectively, spread across my three physical
SPEAKER_00: stats.
SPEAKER_01: Right.
SPEAKER_01: And Sashi is definitely, like, leaking hydraulic fluid.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: In need of repair.
SPEAKER_00: Your check engine light came on.
SPEAKER_02: You know, I think I really tried to do a decent job with you guys.
SPEAKER_00: Versace, would that be a mechanic check when getting back to base?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, we've done it once before.
SPEAKER_00: We'll figure it out.
SPEAKER_01: But I'm good enough to move.
SPEAKER_01: I'm imagining Sachi also has just like one piece of electrical tape to cover the
SPEAKER_01: check engine light.
SPEAKER_01: Nothing's wrong.
SPEAKER_03: It's actually like a floral decorative washi tape,
SPEAKER_01: like
SPEAKER_01: filigree art over myself, like a notebook.
SPEAKER_01: So by hook or by crook, you guys get back to the Transtar apartment with your
SPEAKER_01: shotgun shredded uniforms and
SPEAKER_01: leaking DNA across the floor. Yeah,
SPEAKER_01: so everyone's now back in the apartment.
SPEAKER_03: You guys look like you need drink.
SPEAKER_03: I've had more fun days than
SPEAKER_03: that.
SPEAKER_00: It went pretty smoothly, all things considered.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I think I patched people up pretty well, I'm gonna say, considering that, you
SPEAKER_02: know, that's not my thing.
SPEAKER_00: So would a medic check be for surgery, or is there a different thing for that?
SPEAKER_01: So here's the thing. If you guys want to do surgery on him on the dining
SPEAKER_01: room table, we can deal with that.
SPEAKER_01: You're actually going to be doing surgery.
SPEAKER_01: You're going to be opening him up. You're going to be pulling metal out of him.
SPEAKER_01: Would that be a medic check?
SPEAKER_01: It is a medic check. My question is, do you want to literally be doing that
SPEAKER_01: on the dining room table?
SPEAKER_03: Will he survive without it?
SPEAKER_02: Well, he's been stabilized. So, yes, he'll survive without it.
SPEAKER_02: The question is, can we take him to our companies like medical facilities?
SPEAKER_02: And the truth of it is, either we're staying anyway and we'll make the money to
SPEAKER_02: pay it back, or we're going to run and it's going to be irrelevant what we
SPEAKER_02: owe.
SPEAKER_01: Or
SPEAKER_01: you do it on the table and no one finds anything out if you guys have
SPEAKER_01: great rolls.
SPEAKER_02: Does anyone have a particularly good medic?
SPEAKER_02: Because I don't think we have crazy medics.
SPEAKER_00: I have a medic plus two.
SPEAKER_02: That's not great.
SPEAKER_00: What's your education?
SPEAKER_00: Oh, my education is plus two.
SPEAKER_00: That's not bad. It's a plus four. I will boon him.
SPEAKER_00: That's actually a pretty damn good roll for you guys to randomly be exploring
SPEAKER_01: in Steinbuck's chest.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_02: As you wish.
SPEAKER_02: I would rather take him to, you know, a medical bay, but it's not my life,
SPEAKER_02: so it's up to you guys. It's okay. Put stick in mouth.
SPEAKER_03: Be quiet.
SPEAKER_00: I have a medic to an education of plus one.
SPEAKER_00: Can I assist him?
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so the way I'm going to do that, because he's arguing probably by the
SPEAKER_01: leadership. So first of all, the leadership, but I'm going to figure out how we're
SPEAKER_01: going to do this.
SPEAKER_01: I'm
SPEAKER_01: going to say this.
SPEAKER_01: It would normally be equalized because you guys are doing surgery without a surgery
SPEAKER_01: at all, or like a doctor's office, or a med bay.
SPEAKER_01: That would normally be a bane.
SPEAKER_01: This leadership would make it equal. I would say with Zoi aiding, you're back to a
SPEAKER_01: boon.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, let's do the boon one.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So, Alan, feel free to roll your medicine roll.
SPEAKER_03: With a boon, right?
SPEAKER_03: With a boon.
SPEAKER_03: Wow.
SPEAKER_03: Yay!
SPEAKER_01: One off of perfect. Holy shit, yeah.
SPEAKER_03: Steinbach, you want your dex before you want your strength back, right?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, and nine is where it kicks over, so yeah, I want the dex back, and
SPEAKER_00: then whatever's left is strength.
SPEAKER_00: Okay,
SPEAKER_00: so you're healing 14.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, that leaves me just down two Strength and down five Endurance.
SPEAKER_01: Zero,
SPEAKER_01: two Strengths, five Endurance.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so that is the
SPEAKER_01: first part of the surgery. That is basically four hours.
SPEAKER_01: They can keep going.
SPEAKER_03: Would I keep going with the Boon?
SPEAKER_03: You've lost the leadership.
SPEAKER_03: You would be going with a neutral.
SPEAKER_03: Do you want me to keep going?
SPEAKER_03: He has a great fucking role, man.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, I think we keep pushing it.
SPEAKER_00: Ken, does anyone else have leadership
SPEAKER_01: to inspire
SPEAKER_00: me?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, the guy on the fucking table who's been put under for you to be ripping
SPEAKER_01: pellets at me
SPEAKER_00: sometimes.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, fine.
SPEAKER_00: So I'll keep it as normal then when I roll again now, right?
SPEAKER_03: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: All right, well, I hope you don't die.
SPEAKER_01: A
SPEAKER_01: four, that's a great success. Man, you actually are healed.
SPEAKER_01: So the gist of it is...
SPEAKER_01: I am your dentist.
SPEAKER_01: You are wrapped up in druggie, and I would say that you're basically...
SPEAKER_01: Build character.
SPEAKER_01: Basically, because you guys had the double medics that actually had a decent amount,
SPEAKER_01: because Zoe and Alan, you negated the aspect of basically doing it on a kitchen
SPEAKER_01: table.
SPEAKER_00: I give Zoe a high five.
SPEAKER_01: Can we do Saichi?
SPEAKER_01: So, people who are
SPEAKER_01: not in the leadership group, or those two, or the unconscious, could do mechanics to
SPEAKER_01: help Saichi.
SPEAKER_00: Can I help after? Because, like, I have a plus two mechanic as well.
SPEAKER_00: No.
SPEAKER_01: This is literally you guys doing eight hours of constant surgery.
SPEAKER_01: You're not.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Understood.
SPEAKER_01: Does anyone have a mechanic other than that?
SPEAKER_01: Like, Cole, you gave the first leadership, so you're out.
SPEAKER_01: Josh, actually, Josh, it's a new scene. You can try to do another Great Waters.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: I mean, I have mechanic, but I'm also unconscious, or just regaining.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, I honestly, I think Josh is really the only one who knew, because I don't
SPEAKER_01: think Lauren has any mechanics, or...
SPEAKER_00: I do not believe I do. I'm looking at my sheet, I just don't know where
SPEAKER_00: it's under.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, I'd call it that. It's only out. It's only out.
SPEAKER_00: It's its own thing.
SPEAKER_00: I see medic.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, there it is, it's under, okay, I see it.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, it's between leadership and medical.
SPEAKER_00: Yep, I have it at negative three.
SPEAKER_01: Okay,
SPEAKER_01: so yeah.
SPEAKER_01: If Josh is not here, I'm going to just roll for Josh.
SPEAKER_01: Josh asks you here, you're here, you're not here.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, I was muted. No, no, I'm here. I've been talking for a while.
SPEAKER_02: I just thought you all weren't replying to me.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, so what I was saying is I have robotics, but my mechanic is better.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, but you'd prefer it for the robotics?
SPEAKER_01: No, no, no. You can roll mechanics.
SPEAKER_01: I'm considering robotics as, like, the first aid, and mechanics as you're taking
SPEAKER_01: time.
SPEAKER_01: Okie dokie.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, that's it.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, my God.
SPEAKER_03: I broke
SPEAKER_03: it.
SPEAKER_00: I am a delicate, fancy piece of machinery.
SPEAKER_02: I guess I should have used robotics is what I should have done.
SPEAKER_00: Despite all the armor, I am a Flintall.
SPEAKER_03: Oh no.
SPEAKER_03: Do I not bleed?
SPEAKER_02: I guess the good news is it wasn't a botch.
SPEAKER_02: That's the good news.
SPEAKER_00: I mean, you might have butted a gasket, but yeah.
SPEAKER_02: I can guess it's better than Saichi needs to re-roll a new character.
SPEAKER_01: I
SPEAKER_01: will say that you've stopped Saichi's leaks.
SPEAKER_00: Good.
SPEAKER_00: But you've created more, different ones, somewhere else.
SPEAKER_01: Well, like, no, you're like, you know, you don't need that piece of armor.
SPEAKER_01: I could just shove it in this hole next to that leaky pine cone.
SPEAKER_02: Sorry.
SPEAKER_02: I just want to note that there was no one helping me with leadership and boons,
SPEAKER_02: okay?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: And it was a plus four
SPEAKER_02: roll, okay? It was a plus four, and it still went to a minus one.
SPEAKER_00: Sure. No, you gave it your all.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, you did great.
SPEAKER_00: You did great. It just, you didn't do great.
SPEAKER_02: The
SPEAKER_02: RNG, the last roll was phenomenal. The RNG is just not, I guess I was done.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So, you guys have a lot of data. You guys actually have some cash.
SPEAKER_01: You could use the cash to professionally repair a net.
SPEAKER_03: I'm
SPEAKER_03: down.
SPEAKER_03: Wheel me down to fries!
SPEAKER_00: Could we take Sachi to a repair station? I feel like there's fewer questions with a
SPEAKER_00: robot getting messed up than a person getting messed up.
SPEAKER_00: Is there a micro center?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, exactly. You guys just got a fair amount of credits.
SPEAKER_01: You got 200,000 credits right now from them.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, I meant to go to Transtar's repair bay.
SPEAKER_01: Like, keep it in the house. Oh, so you could say why...
SPEAKER_01: What are you going to say that she was damaged by?
SPEAKER_01: Weapons malfunction?
SPEAKER_02: It was in the last action that we had done when those people were under the
SPEAKER_02: water, and we just didn't get around to repairing yet.
SPEAKER_01: Anyone who wants to throw an admin role to try and start to repair her, I'm
SPEAKER_01: happy to accept that role.
SPEAKER_00: Admin is based off of what? That sounds like you, yeah.
SPEAKER_03: I'm going to leadership that.
SPEAKER_03: I'm going to...
SPEAKER_00: I've admitted zero, but I have...
SPEAKER_00: Is it intelligence? Is it...
SPEAKER_01: Josh got a plus three on the roll.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, okay. I'm going to watch leadership tier.
SPEAKER_01: Sorry. I need a call for leadership because I'm waiting for the actual roll.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_02: I did say I'm going to leadership. I said it out loud.
SPEAKER_01: I'm sorry.
SPEAKER_00: Maybe it was me.
SPEAKER_00: It's all right. I use education.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, so... I have an admin with a small bonus.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, because if it's based on education, my education is three, so that's my bonus
SPEAKER_00: because I only have admin at zero.
SPEAKER_00: So if you've got...
SPEAKER_00: Your plus three is going to be bigger than my total bonus.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, okay.
SPEAKER_00: But I did get a boon?
SPEAKER_00: Yes. Just want to clarify on that? Okay.
SPEAKER_03: I have faith in you.
SPEAKER_01: Oh my god.
SPEAKER_00: They're going to fully repair her.
SPEAKER_01: Cool. I get...
SPEAKER_00: A touch-up job and to get the sticker for my next 50,000 miles.
SPEAKER_00: I feel like it's that scene from Wizard of Oz where they're like polishing it.
SPEAKER_00: I was thinking the same thing.
SPEAKER_00: So she now has a Transtar logo.
SPEAKER_01: Exactly. The problem is, especially now, is repair plates have Transtar swag on
SPEAKER_01: them.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: That's awesome.
SPEAKER_01: So if you ever need to pretend to be a trans-star robot, you're like, see?
SPEAKER_01: See? I got a Turbo Tim's bumper sticker on my ass.
SPEAKER_00: Turbo Tim's.
SPEAKER_00: What's the cap?
SPEAKER_00: You get 10% off, though, if you've got a Turbo Tim bumper sticker.
SPEAKER_01: So Turbo Tim's is a local joint that Laura has fallen in love with because all
SPEAKER_01: of their locations have caps.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, they just have shop cats, but they have like 15 of them, not just like
SPEAKER_00: one or two. Yeah, like there's a room devoted to the cats.
SPEAKER_00: The waiting room has all the cat trees and stuff in it.
SPEAKER_00: So you just, you show up and you pet two cats that are lounging on the
SPEAKER_00: desk. And then you go in the other room and pet the other cats.
SPEAKER_00: And then there's cats in helping with the cars because they're everywhere.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah,
SPEAKER_00: it's pretty great.
SPEAKER_00: You go there after hours and you stare at them through the glass.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Annette does.
SPEAKER_00: Well, I have, because I've had to drop my car off, and you're like, what is
SPEAKER_00: that moving in the windows? And I'm like, oh, it's the 101 cats.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, it's the cats at the windows, because people come for late-night drop-off.
SPEAKER_00: Anyway, yeah, so.
SPEAKER_03: Funny stuff. So I'm... Do I have to push a button to repair?
SPEAKER_03: No,
SPEAKER_03: I've done it all. Oh, cool. There it goes.
SPEAKER_03: Boom, boom.
SPEAKER_03: Boom.
SPEAKER_03: And...
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So, you guys have the data.
SPEAKER_01: You guys have to decide now. Are you guys going to go back to Transtar as
SPEAKER_01: the weekend ends?
SPEAKER_00: This is a hell of a weekend.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, a very rough weekend for Victor.
SPEAKER_01: Victor's like, I'm not hungover, you know?
SPEAKER_01: Oh, no. I'm hungover from the opiates.
SPEAKER_02: So, the question is, is there any way for us
SPEAKER_02: To replicate that, or it's just the slide and there's no way to make a copy?
SPEAKER_01: Well, the whole point of the slides is you have physical proof.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, and I was wondering, can you make a duplicate so we can send it to
SPEAKER_02: someone else? But then it wouldn't be physical proof.
SPEAKER_02: Fair enough.
SPEAKER_01: I just figured it's worth asking.
SPEAKER_01: No, this is literally like what you would like have in the evidence locker.
SPEAKER_03: This is the actual evidence.
SPEAKER_01: There are a few angles you guys can go. By the way,
SPEAKER_01: you can go to the political figures that are actually affected by this since their
SPEAKER_01: names are on it.
SPEAKER_02: But what if they want to kill us because we have bad information that someone could
SPEAKER_02: have used to blackmail them?
SPEAKER_01: They're giving options, Josh. Not saying they're good options.
SPEAKER_02: He's like, I'm gonna admit that that's a terrible option.
SPEAKER_01: You guys could do another Transcar Week just to keep undercover.
SPEAKER_01: You guys could
SPEAKER_01: use your $200,000 and I'll take, or fly the,
SPEAKER_01: because the ship's going to be repaired by the end of the weekend, you could fly
SPEAKER_01: your ship's bike to
SPEAKER_01: This planet where you know the Sol-Sec guy
SPEAKER_01: was interrogating the Sol-Sec personality person about these psychers.
SPEAKER_00: My thought would be
SPEAKER_00: the samples and the data get put as part of the dead drop package to go
SPEAKER_00: to the
SPEAKER_00: journalist.
SPEAKER_03: And then, yeah,
SPEAKER_00: the TransStar stuff is kind of cushy, and it keeps us away from the law for
SPEAKER_00: right now.
SPEAKER_00: So maybe we do another week of TransStar, and then next weekend we fly to the
SPEAKER_00: other planet. Or how long is the round-trip flight to the other planet?
SPEAKER_00: Is it going to be a
SPEAKER_00: day?
SPEAKER_03: Is it going to
SPEAKER_03: be a day?
SPEAKER_03: Probably a day.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: So if we wait until next weekend... You're going to spend some time there?
SPEAKER_01: So, yeah.
SPEAKER_01: If you guys want to do another Transtar Weekend, you guys can do another Transtar
SPEAKER_01: Weekend.
SPEAKER_01: Because you guys do realize when you guys ditch your jobs, you guys are going to
SPEAKER_01: be persona non grata and Transtar is not going to be protecting you from the law.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah.
SPEAKER_02: Well, we don't get the feeling they're going to narc on us.
SPEAKER_02: They're just going to be like, okay, well, you used up your 30 days.
SPEAKER_02: Are you staying? We can be like, actually, we're not going to stay and it's not
SPEAKER_02: a problem.
SPEAKER_01: But you haven't used your 30 days.
SPEAKER_02: Oh,
SPEAKER_02: so then what if we just stay to the last day, right?
SPEAKER_02: Then we leave.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, that's fine.
SPEAKER_01: This has literally been seven days.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, we are one of four.
SPEAKER_02: So what do you guys think? I think, let's wait until it's over.
SPEAKER_02: Thanks, no thanks.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, I mean, I'm, oh, go ahead.
SPEAKER_01: Go ahead, Laura, let us see.
SPEAKER_01: Well, let's let Laura speak and then I'll say my piece.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, I just was saying, I feel like we should ride Transtar as long as we
SPEAKER_00: can because we can be doing both things.
SPEAKER_00: We can be investigating while under their umbrella of safety.
SPEAKER_00: If we leave that umbrella, it
SPEAKER_00: makes us having to find investigative elements like three times harder.
SPEAKER_00: Yep. And my only...
SPEAKER_00: Yep, my only counter to that is
SPEAKER_00: as long as we don't keep feathering ourselves to Transstar such that we become more
SPEAKER_00: indebted to them, you know, because that could become a hard tether to escape even
SPEAKER_00: as we're trying to beat these allegations.
SPEAKER_02: Do you think Patrick would do that to us?
SPEAKER_02: That doesn't sound like something a storyteller would do.
SPEAKER_00: I
SPEAKER_00: got stickers now.
SPEAKER_00: I'm just saying.
SPEAKER_00: I got stickers now.
SPEAKER_01: I got stickers.
SPEAKER_01: Here's my one thing that you guys should think about.
SPEAKER_01: Mercer is still sitting at a base that could be assassinated at any moment.
SPEAKER_03: That is very true. If you guys are going to go do transtar stuff, no one's
SPEAKER_03: going
SPEAKER_01: to be sitting defending him.
SPEAKER_01: And his data all just went down the lines of the Secret Service because the Solstack
SPEAKER_01: agent
SPEAKER_03: took the hand scan.
SPEAKER_00: Can
SPEAKER_00: Laura's character have enough of an executive authority to assign a couple of us to
SPEAKER_00: quote-unquote maintenance in the same area as Mercer so that two of us
SPEAKER_00: could act as guards?
SPEAKER_00: Well, some of us are literally security.
SPEAKER_01: I would let an admin role
SPEAKER_01: hide Mercer on the profunder.
SPEAKER_01: Ooh, I like that.
SPEAKER_00: Hold on, I'm writing a note.
SPEAKER_00: What was the name of the planet that this Camille person went to?
SPEAKER_00: It started with a P.
SPEAKER_01: Camille went to, I'm pulling it up,
SPEAKER_01: Solar System, Providence.
SPEAKER_01: Providence.
SPEAKER_01: By the way, just so everyone has a concept, because it's going to happen more often,
SPEAKER_01: this is the
SPEAKER_03: planetary systems.
SPEAKER_00: And I just want to repeat again, or clarify again, and I apologize.
SPEAKER_00: Camille was going to go and visit who on Providence?
SPEAKER_00: Because I just realized I never made a note for that.
SPEAKER_01: Executive of Social Solidarity to be interrogated.
SPEAKER_00: Social Solidarity, yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Are any of the various moons inhabited?
SPEAKER_00: Many of them.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Allion and Retsaland actually have oxygen atmospheres.
SPEAKER_01: Cool.
SPEAKER_01: Doreena
SPEAKER_01: and Sanctuary have underground bases.
SPEAKER_01: And the rest are kind of more Titan Mooney like where there's going to be a
SPEAKER_01: base or two, but not like a ton of people.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, cool. Thank you for the clarification.
SPEAKER_01: No. Okay.
SPEAKER_03: Sorry, go ahead.
SPEAKER_00: I was going to say, well, I'm rolling something.
SPEAKER_00: I don't remember what I'm rolling.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, that's what I was going to ask. But maybe someone wanted to give you some
SPEAKER_02: coaching first.
SPEAKER_01: Didn't you just roll with
SPEAKER_03: leadership, Josh?
SPEAKER_03: Then yes, sure.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: Come on. There we go.
SPEAKER_03: I don't want to be too hammy about it, but I also wanted to be hammy
SPEAKER_03: about it.
SPEAKER_01: Two's enough that you guys can hide him on as cargo.
SPEAKER_00: I
SPEAKER_00: hope he doesn't mind the smell.
SPEAKER_01: And you're like, you're a loader now, Senator.
SPEAKER_00: Senator Loader.
SPEAKER_02: He's like, I don't like the smell. I'm like, hmm, does death smell better to you?
SPEAKER_00: Damn.
SPEAKER_01: Um...
SPEAKER_01: And I imagine you guys are going to hide. Oh, no, you're going to leave the
SPEAKER_01: ship at the repair dock until you're ready to fly it, I can imagine.
SPEAKER_00: Right.
SPEAKER_00: Because it's actually owned by the other person that Laura, the other person's name
SPEAKER_00: that Laura put on.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, it's owned by, I don't know, I never designated one of my contacts, but it's
SPEAKER_00: owned by one of those contacts. Jamie McDreamerson, I think, is what we said, yeah.
SPEAKER_01: The one issue that's going to come into play, by the way, if you guys spend
SPEAKER_01: your entire month at Transtar, is someone's going to have to pay for those docking
SPEAKER_01: fees.
SPEAKER_03: Uh-oh.
SPEAKER_00: Well, hey, we happen to have 200,000 credits.
SPEAKER_02: Why don't we calculate that now and save that amount of money for everything else?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: To be generous, you're looking at probably 2,000 a day.
SPEAKER_01: You're looking at
SPEAKER_03: another 20 days.
SPEAKER_03: So 40K in docking Vs.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, not a ton.
SPEAKER_03: I mean, that's still 20% of what we found, but sure.
SPEAKER_03: Easy come, easy go, Fremont. That's the truth.
SPEAKER_01: That's how things travel in Traveler.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So, I think we have a plan and a direction.
SPEAKER_01: Next game will be another Transar Day.
SPEAKER_01: Back on the undersea voyages of the Profoundur.
SPEAKER_01: And he's got a lot of questions of like, well, where did you guys put the
SPEAKER_01: ship?
SPEAKER_01: Who the hell is this dude?
SPEAKER_01: My cousin Jimmy? You
SPEAKER_01: know, Jimmy always wanted to see the inside of the subway.
SPEAKER_01: So,
SPEAKER_01: I hope you guys had fun.
SPEAKER_03: There was a good combat, good investigation.
SPEAKER_00: People got all their things. Great game.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Totally fun.
SPEAKER_02: I guess it made sense for me to come anyway.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, you totally kept people alive. So, I mean...
SPEAKER_01: I don't think Steinbach would be alive.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Without that first aid role being as successful, he wouldn't have gotten back up.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah.
SPEAKER_02: I'm not even supposed to be here for this shooting.
SPEAKER_02: And you're like, what if you put that Band-Aid on me?
SPEAKER_02: I'm like, maybe, sure.
SPEAKER_01: I do also say that, like, Alan's, like, super surgery, like, getting Steinbach to
SPEAKER_01: not be basically a Colby Game of Thrones.
SPEAKER_02: I remember that. That's funny.
SPEAKER_02: Weeks.
SPEAKER_00: Weeks of not doing anything.
SPEAKER_00: Thank you all for making my character, you know, still alive.
SPEAKER_01: When Colm says weeks, I need to really clarify this.
SPEAKER_01: I think he had three weeks of being ill, and you're like, oh, that's not so
SPEAKER_01: bad. We were playing day by day.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: One game was one day. Yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER_03: Remember, I took
SPEAKER_00: the tough feat, and I got like three extra hit points out of it, basically, and
SPEAKER_00: I was like, is
SPEAKER_01: this really going to be? And every time I took a wound, it was like, if
SPEAKER_01: you had gotten one more, I would have been cold for that game.
SPEAKER_01: And I took like seven hits during that campaign.
SPEAKER_01: Right.
SPEAKER_01: My guy was very much, I don't want to get hit.
SPEAKER_01: That's why I have an entourage.
SPEAKER_03: You, me, and my guards!
SPEAKER_00: It was still worth it.
SPEAKER_01: So next week, I'm going to try to gather people together to have an in-person game,
SPEAKER_01: and we're going to see how that works.
SPEAKER_01: I hope it goes well.
SPEAKER_01: Now, the week after that,
SPEAKER_01: we are going to not be playing on the 21st.
SPEAKER_01: The 21st is Yom Kippur.
SPEAKER_02: That makes sense.
SPEAKER_00: Why do we not complain that day?
SPEAKER_02: Yes. I thought, Yom Kippur, are you sure?
SPEAKER_02: So the 11th, it starts by Shoshana. Oh yeah, it's Sunday night into Monday night, I
SPEAKER_02: see.
SPEAKER_01: Right.
SPEAKER_01: So the 21st. And it's also like the least day you have to take off methodology
SPEAKER_01: of the entire high holiday method.
SPEAKER_01: Like, there is literally only, I think, four days you have to take off the entire
SPEAKER_01: high holidays.
SPEAKER_03: It's pretty good this year.
SPEAKER_01: So, the 21st is going to be a no-go.
SPEAKER_01: I'm going to work with players to see if we want to try to find a
SPEAKER_01: day that week, or if we just want to
SPEAKER_01: push it to a month of the 5th,
SPEAKER_01: because that week is also the week that my dad's in town, but I imagine he's
SPEAKER_01: not going to want to hang out with me at 8.30.
SPEAKER_01: So...
SPEAKER_01: I will try to be in touch with people of what is viable times.
SPEAKER_01: If people have a suggestion, feel free to put it in this Traveler chat.
SPEAKER_00: Can we coordinate through Traveler chat so that everyone can see it?
SPEAKER_00: Because some things get lost on Messenger.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, if you guys have a thing that deals directly with just the Traveler game,
SPEAKER_01: yeah, go ahead and put it here.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, thanks.
SPEAKER_00: Other than my recovery, which doesn't seem to impede gaming in the least,
SPEAKER_00: I've got nothing blocking me, so I'm pretty open.
SPEAKER_01: I'm in this weird phase of where I'm going to be having a lot of high
SPEAKER_01: holidays, and I'm going to have a lot of work,
SPEAKER_01: and then I'm going to be in Florida.
SPEAKER_01: Wait, so are you coming to New York still?
SPEAKER_01: The problem is
SPEAKER_01: the day of
SPEAKER_01: Alan's wedding is a Sunday, okay?
SPEAKER_01: That Monday morning, I need to be in Florida giving a presentation at 10 in the
SPEAKER_01: morning.
SPEAKER_02: I hear that. I'm not saying you should. I'm just wondering if you're still coming.
SPEAKER_01: No, so I'm trying to figure out what's going on.
SPEAKER_01: One of my co-workers said, oh, you probably can flake the first day, but we won't
SPEAKER_01: know until the schedule's done. It may just be partner day.
SPEAKER_01: So I gotta figure out what's going on.
SPEAKER_01: But
SPEAKER_01: if you did want to come for His Sheva Brockus, you could come for those days.
SPEAKER_02: You mean...
SPEAKER_01: I found out that my fiancé and her family, when they were making deals with the
SPEAKER_01: Hall and stuff,
SPEAKER_00: Half of the wedding has to be paid for in cash, apparently.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, wow.
SPEAKER_00: And I was like, why?
SPEAKER_03: And I was like, not my plan.
SPEAKER_03: That's not my plan.
SPEAKER_00: You know?
SPEAKER_01: Wow.
SPEAKER_00: That's intense.
SPEAKER_00: Apparently, they got a good deal on it, but I'm just like, hey, hey,
SPEAKER_02: hey, hey. You're like, you do know I'm not a drug dealer, right?
SPEAKER_00: Oh my gosh, yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Could you be? That would be so helpful.
SPEAKER_00: Dude, I don't know
SPEAKER_00: why I'm not making babysitters, babysitting stuff.
SPEAKER_00: We got the blueprint.
SPEAKER_00: But, like, no.
SPEAKER_00: It's kind of crazy. I am happy I got a job when I landed here.
SPEAKER_00: But, like,
SPEAKER_00: that is...
SPEAKER_03: It's been heavy on the mind.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah.
SPEAKER_03: That was funny. It's like, you have cash?
SPEAKER_03: No.
SPEAKER_00: No. You're right. You're right. Yes, I have cash.
SPEAKER_00: I have a $20 bill. Right?
SPEAKER_00: I will contribute.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, yeah. Right. Because until even the house is sold, you don't have physical cash
SPEAKER_01: like that.
SPEAKER_03: No.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah.
SPEAKER_03: I don't know.
SPEAKER_03: Whatever.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: So...
SPEAKER_02: I'm wishing you the best, man. That's rough.
SPEAKER_02: I mean, that's a rough one.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: So, Josh, if his plans are that intense, my plans are only less so.
SPEAKER_02: Well, I put it in my calendar. It'll let me know what's up.
SPEAKER_01: Yes.
SPEAKER_01: But yeah, I will be pushing people more for a solid date next week, but I
SPEAKER_01: just want people to realize the 21st is
SPEAKER_01: a no-go.
SPEAKER_00: I can't come on the 21st either.
SPEAKER_03: It's funny that. No, you can't.
SPEAKER_01: It's
SPEAKER_01: the only reason.
SPEAKER_02: We'll give you an excuse this time.
SPEAKER_01: Well, it's also silly, though.
SPEAKER_01: I don't think it starts on the Monday. I think it starts at the end of
SPEAKER_01: Sunday, right?
SPEAKER_00: Of course, yeah. It's Sunday night.
SPEAKER_01: So, like, one could argue, like, oh, we'll break fast and have game.
SPEAKER_03: Interesting.
SPEAKER_01: You know, what's up?
SPEAKER_01: Fast is going to end at like 8.20 something.
SPEAKER_00: I don't think I'll have the emotional capacity for that.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, neither will I. I'm just making sillies.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah. Maybe if we were 16. Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: So
SPEAKER_01: we'll see you whenever. Don't worry. We're going to make it work.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So, everyone have a great night, and thank you all for coming.
SPEAKER_01: I appreciate everyone who takes the time and effort to come to these.
SPEAKER_01: Thank you very much. Thank
SPEAKER_00: you, guys. Thank you for the time and effort in running these.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah. 100%.
SPEAKER_00: I have a lot of fun.
SPEAKER_01: One question, since I'm now paranoid about needing a character when I die.
SPEAKER_01: What's the budget for a robot?
SPEAKER_01: We did a million times.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.